Wow hello hello everybody oh my gosh my voice is so holy I
woke up like an hour ago I won the gotcha guys I did it I
told you I told you I'll happen I won the nap gotcha I told
you anyway I woke up an hour ago so my throat is not warmed
up yet at all for talking it's like pretty fucked right now
I also got back from uh from a dad walk today uh well not
just today obviously i do walk my time i just got back from
i didn't i just got back from dog walkies um there was a
little child there and a little child really really wanted
to approach dad but it's always like a gamble because i
don't know how he's like 50 50 with kids and i don't like my
odds when it comes to dogs and kids you know um i don't want
you know i don't want to give them trauma because then the
parent is there too so like you know obviously i didn't want
to i was like i have a stream today i don't want to get
yelled at by a parent for like the next 10 to 15 minutes so
yeah so i really didn't want the kid to approach my dog i
didn't want my dog to approach the kid um so the kid kept
wanting to get near my dog and I was like pulling him away
because you know I don't trust my odds when it comes to uh
when it comes to my dog and children um because he would
most likely just bark at the child and then give the child
trauma and uh the parent was there so I didn't want him to
do that um anyway uh so uh the child left their tricycle at
the park and I guess because I guess I picked correct in the
gotcha He went up to the bicycle the tricycle and then start
squatting and pooping right next to the tricycle And I'm
like of course you picked that spot there were so many other
spots Leading up to this child's bike and you decided to
poop right next to the bicycle he's like this is my tricycle
now yeah and then obviously you know the the parent was on
the phone so she was not giving a about what's going on and
then the kid was just staring at us i was like i'm so sorry
like i was just like i i i can't control when he poops he's
got a poop you know i i i i would i would yank him it was
any other part but he's pooping i can't yank him in the mid
had to send a message yeah they was like this land is mine
now that's what you get for leaving your tricycle here like
so so yeah i just got back from dog walking just all new
announcements well there's like one new announcement in that
but but we just announced our second guest for the
Also, next thing, again, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have to pull it up because I forgot to save it.
Let me pull it up real quick, guys.
We have to save the PNG.
Bap, bap, bap, bap.
All right.
Thumbnail.
Oh, I saved it in the thumbnail folder.
Or whatever.
It's in the thumbnail folder now.
All right.
Bap, bap, bap, bap, bap, bap.
Where is it?
Where is this PNG?
Yes, if you guys do not follow Twitter, you don't have a
Twitter account.
It's a doobie!
She doobie in my concert!
Yay!
The surprise of no one.
Yes, doobie will be participating in the Dokey Dokey Rewind
Time concert.
July 4th.
Yes, she is singing more than one song.
And I'm super excited to sing with Duby.
I'll give you a little hint, a little spoiler.
But you do know she's very into Skaterpunk.
So she actually picked the song, the one of the songs that
we will be doing together.
And I was so happy that we did have perms for it.
She was like, oh, like, I was like, here's a list of songs.
and she's like oh but do they have this song it's like oh my
god wait this song is fucking sick i was like oh my god i
was like oh that song is fucking sick it was not in our
perms it was not in the list i gave her when you know like i
i had like a giant list of songs that were clear for perms i
was like oh my god i hope i really do hope that uh we have
perms for that one and we did excited to sing this song that
she picked for us um but anyway uh super excited announced
to be um as my second guest uh for the doki doki rewind time
uh next three days we're gonna announce another guest as
well it keeps going until all the guest announcements are
done but you guys want to buy tickets we did also released
uh the last round of vip tickets so if you weren't able It's
today's the day to grab another grab a VIP ticket for the
concert It's the last round that we will be releasing for
and another that's just general admissions So yes, thank you
again everyone for the huge support on dokey dokey rewind
time We sold out the first round and early The early
admissions ticket too So thank you again everyone for the
huge amount of support for this concert so far I really look
forward to seeing all of you guys and i look forward to
seeing you guys online when the streaming tickets do go out
we're still working on it so um um i heard that people were
asking how much the streaming tickets would be i think it's
i i was looking up last year's fantastic i should ask them
actually i should be like hey what's what how much the
streaming tickets are because some people were asking how
much it's gonna be i assume it's gonna be around the same
price range as last year's fantastic reality does anyone
remember fantastic realities uh last year's streaming ticket
uh streaming ticket fee for it uh i i don't want to do like
100 promise we are working on it i just assume that um it
will be like you know you know negotiations and stuff like
that uh takes a while and i do know like mince concerts like
the densest concert hasn't even put out their streaming
ticket uh um streaming tickets online yet too so um soon it
just takes a while to negotiate for it but they are still
working on it so yeah there's another announcement uh
another announcement for our guest for the new guest for my
concert uh i know it wasn't like that expensive those
streaming tickets let me see i think it was like it's via
spawn so um i'm pretty sure i can just grab a record off of
it oh i can all right last year last year was like around 3
000 yen um i don't know i don't don't take my word for it i
was just i'm just going off last year's so i think that is
around 20ish dollars us dollars for streaming tickets so i i
hope uh i hope we get some news soon of regarding it i
really do uh but not i think it's just gonna be like maybe
like a month or two before a month or too until until like
the streaming ticket negotiation is done but yeah that's
news on the concert what other stuff what announcement i
want to tell you guys oh yes i got jolly bees today i forgot
about the final fantasy collab that they were having i was
so surprised oh yeah let me show you guys the picture of my
jolly bees i was craving the spaghetti the spaghetti so i
was like and i was like looking oh yeah i should get jolly
bees so that's like craving them I know, I love the sweet
pasta sauce.
It's just something about it.
Let me show you guys.
I'm going to make you guys jealous.
I'm going to give you FOMO.
I'm going to give you Jolly Bees FOMO right now.
But for those who don't know, I don't play Final Fantasy
Online.
I don't play Final Fantasy in general.
I don't know.
I love sweet spaghetti.
I love the Jolly Bees spaghetti.
So I got the Final Fantasy Online X Jolly Bees collab.
Anyway, so this collab is only in NA.
So I thought it was so, okay, it might not be funny for
people outside of NA.
But this is only available in NA.
And for those who don't know what Jolly Bees is, it's a type
of fried chicken slash spaghetti.
I know it's just like it's fried chicken and spaghetti
French fast food franchise that originated in the
Philippines Like but yet this collab does not exist in the
Philippines Some people were like what we made you how could
you do this to us?
Yeah Yeah, like so I remember when if the I remember when it
first the collab first came up People were so mad because
they're like, I can't I we made you
How dare you it's so fucked up and Anyway, I Yeah, they
betrayed us and So anyway, I got myself the final fantasy at
Jolly Bees collab I think my favorite part of the the box
that I came with was this particular, oh wait, where was it?
Was this particular side of the box?
I thought it was just really, it was very personal.
Oh yeah, I was gonna show you guys, I was gonna take a
picture of the QR code for one of the dragoons to claim, but
I forgot about it.
Anyway, no chocobos were harmed in the making of this meal.
That's good.
The thing I love the most about Final Fantasies is the Chibi
Chocables.
It's one of my favorite character designs.
See, no cannibalism, guys.
Technically, I didn't cannibalize my own kind.
Anyway, what else do I want to say?
But it was really good.
I was so surprised.
I was so surprised that they still had the boxes and the
stickers.
But I just because I don't know if you guys remember.
um oh it's not just a QR code you have to fill out a form
with info from all right I guess no one's claiming that in
emote then I don't I don't do MMO RPGs so um because uh I
want to say I have a life I want to continue having a life
and also saving money just in case because I very addicting
personality I don't want to get addicted and I I said I want
to say I that's my cover story but wow personal attack but
like also because I do have very addicting personality and I
really don't want to get addicted to a to like MMORPGs
because then I might be subscribed like I will never cancel
the subscription and i i don't not have a lot of time
anymore so i i don't i i just don't want to worry about
getting addicted to mmo rpgs um also like i have i i i have
a what's the word i try to i turn away from mmo rpgs in
general because i was used as a because my dad was super
into world of Warcraft and he forced me well he didn't force
me but he was very uh persuasive of me playing World of
Warcraft with him um because he needed someone to play with
and he just wanted me to be like the healer because he
wouldn't join a fucking guild um so he was like a solo he
was a solo World of Warcraft player but he also needed like
an extra hand to help on some quests and stuff played with
him until he max leveled uh yeah he wanted to be pocketed he
needed a pocket healer so i couldn't play any other
character i could only play the priest so he had a child so
he could get a pocket healer in world he outsourced his
labor so when i was a kid i was basically like being his
pocket healer until he hit max level uh in world of warcraft
and then i was freed and i touched an mmo rpg since um and
it was it and also like i was on like asia servers but i had
to i like down i had to research how to download an english
patch uh to world of warcraft because like if you're on an
asia server it gives you the asia client without like it
gives you the asia client so um but it's all in chinese so
like i was like i can't read chinese how am i supposed to
know what buttons i'm pressing so i have to research on the
internet how to patch it to ink oh my i just remember
spending hours trying to figure out how to fuck to patch the
world of warcraft clients so that at least the texts are in
english and so it was just not not the greatest memory it
was very very tiresome it's very tedious i would like get
home from school and then my dad my dad would be like jokie
it's world of warcraft time hop on like and i was like yes
dad i would boot up world of warcraft and follow him around
on his quest and so that's why i don't play world of i don't
play mmo rpgs anymore after that and you cannot convince me
to play play League of Legends.
I swear to God, it's a psyops or some shit.
They just released a study being like, if you play League
of, I swear it.
I was like, you aren't getting me.
I don't care if apparently there's a there's a new study
right now where that got released where there was a 30 week
study of 68 university students who had no previous gaming
experience and they made them
they made them play league and they're like we found out
league improves attention working memory and executive
function it's like a league player is a league player shows
stronger gains in spatial attention and spatial work i don't
believe it i don't fucking you can't get me you're not
getting you're what yeah you're right what about the
depression what of how does that contribute to the game to
the fucking the gamer where it's being spoken in league i i
doubt that who paid for this study show me the sponsors for
this study i don't believe you're not kidding me it will be
10 years and i still won't touch the league you won't get me
i am i am anti-league strongest warrior like that's insane i
had brainwashed me i ain't no puppet to your games i but yes
i don't believe it i don't fucking believe it i just they
they're lying someone lied a league player broke into the
research facility and fucking numbers on the study.
I...
League is the new tobacco industry.
It's all a conspiracy, guys.
Quick, wear your tinfoil hats.
They'll hear your thoughts.
They're trying to figure out your thinking about League.
They're trying...
So, anyway, there's that.
came up on my social media.
Oh yeah, regarding the Final Fantasy Jolly Bees collab, I
was so surprised that they still, they will make you play
league.
Save yourself to try to make you play league.
Be strong, dragons.
Anyway, I was surprised that they still had the, because the
collab has been around for a while now.
So I was surprised they still even have the Final Fantasy
box or, um, or like the sticker sheet.
And, uh, but I assume it's just not as popular as One Piece
because like, the thing is, I, I assume like it's not like
as mainstream as One Piece because the One Piece stuff sold
out and where it's like lining up.
And people were lining up for it for like on day one and
stuff.
there was more mainstream than Final Fantasy.
Yeah, so I was just so surprised.
Yeah, because I thought they would run out already because
I, you know, I was just like, Ooh, Final Fantasy collab.
I was like, Ooh, they were really cute.
I really like, I was just, I just wanted to see what it
looked like since I was like, might as well since I'm
getting Jolly Bees anyway.
I assume that's why.
Because like, if anyone saw like the one piece of the, was
it Chick-fil-A, did the Chick-fil-A collab?
Oh, it was no, Pop-Eyes.
They did a Pop-Eyes collab with One Piece.
And there was, like, oh, it's similar.
There was a special collaboration.
There was the box, the paper box.
There was, like, the bento boxes on, like, and people were
lining up for them for, like, basically, like, it was like a
four, like, a three to four hour plus wait on day one to
even get the One Piece collab.
And a lot of them, and they were, like, scalping it.
I hate, I hate that.
Like, everything is just scalpers now.
like everyone's just like it won't make quick money just
start scalping and it's like it's fucking frustrating
because it's like not everything is getting scalped at first
it was just pokemon and now like it's everything like
everything that's considered limited edition is now getting
scalped and it's like very frustrating uh i saw like
hololive like cards i saw my twitter feed um i saw hololive
cards were getting scalped too and i saw someone was like
like complaining about uh which is understand was pretty
fucked about how uh there was the uh like a card that was
being scoured for two thousand dollars i was like what the
fuck two thousand like what so like everything anyway um so
like if you guys didn't know the
scalped on on the internet um including like okay wait let's
see i was like bro that's just paper i was like what the
that's just the paper how is that getting scalped um this i
could find the picture of it it was literally like the
cardboard box of where they put the chicken and it's
literally like that was getting scalped and i was just like
what the bro it's just it's really just a cardboard box that
like i don't understand let me say i can find it one piece
of papa's scalpers funded by tensen ride probably somewhere
in them also i have you like thank you the super chat thank
you thank you they won't get me i am strong um let me see i
need to see if i could find the picture of the I saw it on
Twitter, but I didn't save it.
So I want to show you guys like what it was that was getting
scalped and stuff.
Um, I mean, similar Pokemon cards, though.
I mean, that's true of Pokemon, but like, like, it's just a
fucking cardboard box.
I just couldn't believe like that was being sold online for
like, it was like for like, what, $50 or some shit.
It wasn't even like, oh my God, it's so stupid.
for a piece of cardboard like i was like why it was like all
right the luffy bento box um wait that's why i was like i
was just like oh i don't think i don't think i'm gonna be
able to um let's see ebay you know just go on ebay popular
one p oh now it's for eight dot look look at this it's now
eight it was a lot more expensive i'll tell you that oh the
price is finally dropped i wonder why i think it's because
uh you can now get it online so like the prices were finally
fucking dropped thank god this one's worth 30 oh my god look
at that oh wait Nevermind, I can't post.
Let me screenshot this.
Let me screenshot this real quick.
13 people have viewed this today.
12 people were tempted to get this.
They had to actually look.
That's crazy.
That's 12 people too many.
Here.
Here it is.
This is, by the way, a cardboard box where they put the
chicken.
So I...
I don't know why the fuck that I think that's I think
personally that's $29 too many US by the way 30 US dollars
to grab a cardboard box that with with Luffy Luffy on it um
yeah it's like it's literally just a cardboard box that's
why I was like I was like oh I'm so I'm glad I was able to
grab my final fantasy box thank god they don't have a
netflix adapt adaptation yet that yeah yeah 20 even 29 yeah
i think i i that's insane but it's a two-pack what a deal so
they're scalping that's why i'm so surprised that they still
but i think it's just because like final fantasy yeah yeah
that has it doesn't have like mainstream appeal for now
Final Fantasy Online um so thank oh thank God for that and
also I think I don't know if One Piece has the limitation
the Popeyes had limitation but I read that it's like one oh
actually no you can buy as many as you want it's just the
emos that has the uh it's just the emos that has like the
the limitation for it Brady they give a super chat thank you
thank you last super fly because I'd say yep I just got my
dokey coin today not a scam it's great Brady thank you the
super chat thank you thank you i'm so happy that you got the
the coin i'm so happy oh yeah i'm not sure if this is final
if this is confirmed me spreading misinformation but i think
um i think my distributor because my distributor is gonna be
at oh she uplink they might have dokey the mini dokey
plushes being sold the like singular singular plushies being
sold at my booth but don't take my word for it i said might
so if you're going to oshi uplink in canada um maybe check
out the booth i mean there there is a cheat there is a chibi
exclusive charm there as well by my retro doki mama uh my
retro doki mama did draw my chibi charm uh but um no you
promise i'm flying right now but i'm not sure if it's maybe
i should just message i could have just messaged my events
manager and just be like hey just to confirm um i said hey i
was wondering um do i is the plushies being sold at oshi
uplink uh
i wasn't sure if it was confirmed yeah they started they
started sending out the individual orders like because the
coins are already there the acrylic block it's just the
plushies we just we're just waiting because there's a lot of
plushies being main um so we're just waiting on more of the
plushies coming in and then we can send out the bundles and
stuff so that's really i think that's sort the only one
that's missing right now but we have the coins we have the
acrylic block we have the um i think that's it is there
anymore i don't even know let me check uh jokiemerch.com
what are the others um we have everything but the hoodies
yeah oh it's the hoods yeah we have everything but the but
the hoodies that's why we couldn't send out the plushies yet
um but if you order anything else from that like individual
order anything else you should be receiving them soonish
because i know of the coins that like people ordered a coin
individual coins have already have mostly gotten them
already um demon thank you for the magenta super thank you
thank you unfortunately i missed you at oh she uplinked you
no no demon now you can get so oops uh oh i'm sorry demon
like dude's like no now you dumb oh yeah and also for uh for
Oshi Uplink for my panel I'm gonna be 1v1ing dragons uh
usually I don't get that opportunity I think you know it's
always such a unique opportunity because you know it's
usually panels like Q&A or just like a Zatzadon but for my
panel you can 1v1 me in apex I think it's apex I don't know
if it's like like Overwatch or rivals as well but there's a
chance to 1v1 me and you can also watch me 1v1 other dragons
also um but I hope other dragons enjoy the meet and greet
and Yoshi.
Please, please don't use this for gacha.
They even magenta soup, but even they can say don't worry
I'll use it for jolly bees.
Thank you for me.
Magenta soup, but they can thank you.
I'm gonna have to practice apex soon.
Like I need it for if I'm doing one.
It was really a last minute decision because I was like, oh,
it was fun because my event manager was telling me like,
what do you want to do for your panel?
We got to confirm this.
And I was just like, i don't know usually i just go straight
to a q a because that's the easiest and i can gap for like
you know already been yapping for 35 minutes and that's easy
to do but i was like you know it'd be fun to 1v1 dragons
because i thought that was really fun the last time i did it
and people enjoyed watching it so i was like you know what
if there's an opportunity i would love to just want like you
know do one v1s and one v1s and stuff so uh uh so yeah
that's gonna be uh that's going to be uh what the panel will
be most likely because you're getting the equipment and
stuff for that to set uh to set up uh what else what else oh
i had something else to talk about but i slipped my mind
because i went through so many different tangents oh yeah uh
fuck okay give me a sec because i'm trying to remember there
was something else i wanted to talk about but there were so
many tangents going on that i've lost the other tangent in
yet.
Oh, yeah, schedule.
The reason why a schedule hasn't been posted, because I
don't know if I'm in that Marvel rivals tournament.
I was supposed to get confirmation yesterday, but then
they're like, we're still working on the teams and stuff.
So I still don't know.
I don't know if I'm in it.
And that's why, because it's on, it's supposed to be on May
2nd, or first.
It's supposed to be on Friday.
So like, I don't know if I'm participating.
So, um, so I'm just like, That's why I haven't posted my
schedule yet because I don't know Like Because I It was
supposed to be confirmed on Saturday And then it got delayed
and then we were like Oh Sunday will know and it got delayed
And then Monday will know So and they got to the Tuesday
They're like Tuesday we'll find out for real We'll find out
for real If like what's going on That's the only reason i
just i just i don't know i um i think it's because like
they're trying to find enough because they're they're just
trying to balance things out balance the teams out and stuff
so i believe that's because like i know like a lot of people
that was participating last year or not last year sorry like
a couple months ago were uh are like are too busy to come
back um so like they have to find like people to you know
join and stuff so they and also they're they don't know how
to battle if they're like trying to figure out how to
balance them is hard as well um so so that's what like we're
waiting on right now um oh yeah so yesterday i was
practicing rivals um and you know because like i don't know
if i'm i don't know so i might as well i've been i was
practicing rivals because i i don't know i haven't played
rivals in a while um i haven't played rivals consistently i
think the best way to say i haven't played rivals
consistently in a long time like i don't know what meta is
for this season or the last two seasons because i haven't
been playing consistently in rank um so i was trying to
figure out what the meta is and what the bad line is too
because i don't like you know i feel like i'd be doing a lot
of like trying to like strategic thinking on like bad line
and like that so i i don't know what the bad line is i don't
know what is okay black hat is so fucking strong like i like
um It's crazy.
Apparently, like, because Black Cat has, like, 900
abilities, it has 900 abilities.
If you one-trick Black Cat, you can basically destroy the
enemy team because they can technically go invisible
forever.
Because, like, you know, there's no cooldown in stuff in
buying her abilities.
So, like, all the Black Cat one-tricks, but she is
incredibly hard to figure out.
her out in general uh so people don't know how like people
don't know her her well enough unless they're in like super
high elo like the super high elo hat is basically like black
cat bands like first band black cat because um all the
really really good players have already mastered black cat
and i was in two i was in a lobby with one of those black
cat players like the backline basically
Like every new hero that's been released is just so fucking
strong.
Like every new hero that's been released is just permanent
BAM now.
So like, like you literally can't do anything.
Like we had like we had the result to triple support.
And even then like we just get destroyed.
Like because they would just you just die.
You can't outplay it.
Because she would the moment she's 1 HP.
She fucking goes invisible.
And then heals up.
Then comes back and does everything again.
Like you can't kill her.
She just be like now you see me.
like and that happens every five to ten seconds so it's like
what the do you do you can't one v wonder you can't one v
wonder at all you have to have like someone to help you and
even then it's it's like it's like sort of like it's it's
black panther on crack basically like it's so bad anyway so
um yesterday yesterday i got a game with zeal for those who
don't know lucky zeal he's like an infamous spider-man
player and then uh he basically engagement baits all the
time like engagement baits are rage baits all the time and
and um and uh for those who don't know when the bounty board
was first when the bounty board was a thing for those who
don't who don't remember the like course is the spider-man
player but uh remember the story i told you guys about the
how someone made a bounty board um and uh and it got taken
down uh because like rivals was like like the rival dev
stepped in and everything so there was a bounty board where
people can pay to int like throwers and so or int like like
other griefers because they're like teach them a lesson but
then people obviously used it to just throw streamer games
like And you just be like, I hate this streamer.
Please throw his game.
So people just started using it for that instead of like,
you know, the intentional or like the intentional message of
the bounty board.
And you're like, oh, free money.
I can just throw a streamer game.
Anyway, Lucky Zio was the number one bounty.
Like he would have like, I think his, I don't remember what
was the most expensive, but it went up to like $1,000 at one
point just to throw his game.
It was like the number one target on the bounty board.
Anyway, so he asked him if I was the real jokie bird because
I was on his team.
And obviously I said no because like that's my thing.
Like I don't confirm.
I don't confirm if I was the real jokie bird.
And then, but then like, but like, you know, obviously
people would be like, oh no, that is the real jokie because
you can't really steal someone's name like in general,
unless you put space, I guess.
But like I've never had like an impersonator.
like a dokeybird impersonator arrivals yet like in the high
elo you know in the um in the high elo i've never bumped
into a dokeybird impersonator but like but i have said no to
lucky zeal like three times whenever he asked me it's like
in his head he thinks there's like all these random
dokeybird impersonators running around in the lobby like
He thinks there's a bunch of these random fake dokey birds
running around in like Celestial slash in Celestial just
impersonating me and but like the thing is he was like
because I like I always say no whenever he asks um she can
be in it but they're all they're all me like he there's a
bunch of fake dokeyberries running out around like he legit
like he legitimate believes that um because i'm with his
head i did it intentionally i thought he would know like i
thought he would just like he would know it was a joke but
then like he probably has paranoia now is telling his chat
like i don't know if this is the real dokeyboard or the fake
one like i i've bumped into a fake the fake one before and
like So, uh, in the end, it was all actually me.
Like, he was not bumping into any fake jokie bears.
I just kept saying no.
And, and then, and then I was just like, out of nowhere,
after he was like, are you the jokie bear that called me
fat?
And I was just like, what?
Like, I was so confused.
I was like, I was like, what the fuck do you mean?
Like, I, and then I remembered that game.
He's like, are you the one that called me Chubby Zeal?
He called me fat, weren't you?
You were that fake Doki fan.
I was so confused.
I was like, sir, this did not happen.
I don't know what story you constructed in your head, but
that never happened.
I was like, because the thing is, I remember that game.
I remember that game.
And it was someone else on my team that said that to him.
Like, it matched that.
that to me.
He thought that was me that typed it out.
There's literally someone else in that game that fully, that
typed it out and called him that.
And then I don't know why he thought that one was me.
Because I remember that game.
I was like, oh my damn, whoa, whoa.
What the fuck?
Like right off the bat, whoa.
This guy, this guy really hates him I killed yeah I got
killed by association just by being on whoever that guy
whoever that guy was on that guy's team because he was like
I remember because we were against Lucky Zeal and then like
um Lucky Zeal you know asked me that question being like are
you the real donkey bird and I said no like and then some
after I said no someone was like typed below was like um
like you know just type that to him and then I guess he
thought I was the one that typed that like I whoa I can't
believe my own which I didn't even say all I said was no I
didn't even say anything I got blamed for the wrong reasons
and kongo thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
so yeah he thinks there's like a bunch of fake dokey birds
running around and just like like I like it he'll never meet
the real dokey bird but but the plot twist is that they were
all me but i did not insult it i would like to say i did not
insult it oh yeah and then apparently because i played a few
games with super gomez and then super gomez and him had like
one beef like a beefy like a beef moment a couple of months
ago around christmas or some shit so like so then um so then
like uh uh and so so lucky zeo like held that that grudge
against super gomez and then so and then he was like fuck
you super gomez and fuck you dude i was like what the fuck
me for what i didn't know
He was like, we got a bad, uh, we had Doki Finn on the enemy
team.
We got a bad Invis, Loki, and Cook and Dagger.
That's all she plays.
I was like, I was just like, what?
I like rewatched the stream.
And because like, Tipper Gomez was like, oh, I just got
banned from Lucky Zeal's chat.
And I was like, why?
And then so, um, I was just like, why?
Like, I was so curious.
Like, why the fuck did you get banned in the chat?
fuck did you do he's like oh something that happened on
christmas and but he was still it was still he said all the
great about us i like looked at the vibe and then he and
then he like he was like edge hokey וز on the enemy team we
got bad cloak infus and loki and it's cheat and it's easy
win and i was just like what did i do what did i i was like
i was like what did i do
Luna like I was just like if anything thank you for banning
Loki because I I don't like playing Loki right now because I
I so now it's like I was like I could play Luna and there's
still there's still Luna there's so rocket there's still and
we won the game anyway but I was just like wait what fuck me
for I
he was like that was just like why fuck me for who did i do
like like again guilty by association again i even know they
had beef i even know these two had beef and then gomez was
like oh yeah i forgot about that thing that happened he
didn't gomez forgot that that he he forgot he even had beef
with lucky zeal
on this channel because he wanted to be like you I got too
deep into this and I was just like what's going on I'm just
trying to play rivals I just wanted to play Marvel rivals
yeah it was collateral damage yeah anyway let's play uh
story time over let's play mouse vi for i the dst is real
I was just like, what's going on?
All I said, every time he's asked me about that, I've only,
like the only interactions I've had with Lucky's deal is me
typing no.
Every time he's asked, that's the only interaction I've had
with him.
And also all the people on my team that kept trying to be
like that.
And also all the time, like whenever I got him on the enemy
team, would be so locked in.
It would be so locked in trying to win.
I know it's everything for him.
The worst you can say is no.
Post-traumatic Doki syndrome.
Alright.
Back at it again.
all right here we go i remember luckily it's just been two
to three days so i remember the controls hey dokey's my
birthday can't get nor jazzy happy birthday song to match
with the game can't wait to see you all at the dokey dokey
concert parent thank you for the super chat thank you thing
i'm so excited too happy oh wait happy birthday oh wait how
do you do a jazzy version i need like the
but a happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday dear prudent happy birthday to you yeah um but um i
love the soundtrack apparently i found out caravan palace
only did one song for them um so i don't know but we're
already encountered their song or not i love caravan palace
might want to ease up on the cheese sticks jay your hearts
only got so many miles left on it nah it's running on
premium damn premium heart have you yeah my heart is
subscription based all right let's see i think we got
everything here right before we left Is that my car?
Yeah, that's my car.
Oh.
Oh, that's just an outhouse.
Ah, yeah.
Sorry, I had a little bit.
I had martini for dessert as well.
Ah, the good old days.
We can drink and drink.
Please don't drink and drink.
Disclaimer, that's a joke, guys.
Disclaimer, that was a joke.
Please do not drink or drive.
Oh, roadhouse.
What's that?
I've been to the roadhouse?
Toki.
Alright.
Hello, sir.
Oh!
Ammo store.
Okay.
I've been here before?
Oh, no.
Oh, it's like a...
What is it called?
Like a...
brewery oh baseball cards oh there's the the card game that
you guys were telling me about
oh no no what is it called like after you know how they had
an alcohol ban at one point and there's like secret alcohol
places no no i'm talking oh speak easy i don't think this is
a speak easy it's very public right now that they're selling
alcohol all right the match begins split in two rounds in
the first inning you play as a batter and in the second you
oh a squeak easy yeah these the prohibition air yeah yeah
it's a really really and the squeak easy you play as a
pattern and the second you switch to the pitcher okay oh
play as the batter the baseball card game Now let me draw up
to five cards, a full hand.
Alright.
Your opponent plays one of their player cards if you're a
batter to play a pitcher and vice versa.
If you have it leaving hand, your opponent can also play a
second card.
Tactics which boosts the selected player's abilities.
You now play cards from your hand at the bottom.
Oh, it's like that penguin game.
Okay.
A scar to select time and replace with an increased chance
of drawing a tactic.
Return only ends once you select and confirm at least a
player card.
Tactics are optional.
Alright.
Grab.
This and this.
We got a spoo or powers or speed boost.
Play ball.
Wait, what the fuck is cards high?
Bad takes to win.
The batting skill is higher than the pitching skill.
The bat hits the long pams around.
I've written there.
The bat misses.
They're out.
damn it their cards five those are added to the relevant
ability of the pirate draw a batting pitching skill ends up
equal to outcome inside by coin toss oh by chance it's not
fair is that he's he was number five that's it number six
we'll do that just in case i don't know how high the number
goes so oh thank god okay bam no move a number and base is
equal to your speed skill speed is reduced by the current
pitcher fielding skill which can stop a runner in their
tracks don't the batter skill is much higher than the
pitcher the batter hits a home run and all runners run on
base jacquard i think of the super shot chat thing thank you
rival story reminded me of spider mic comic this is why
everyone hates you guys not because you're immune because
you're because Why am I, uh, ass?
I'm just standing.
I know, I was like, what did I do?
I, I'm so confused.
I was just like, why is he target banning me?
What the fuck did I do?
He literally banned.
He literally was like, we gotta, guys, there's Tokey Bird on
the other team.
We gotta ban Loki Cloak.
And I rewatched the fuck.
Cause I was like, damn, it's so weird that they banned three
supports.
I was like, usually they will ban like one support, like
it'll be Gambit or something, or Cloak, and then they'll ban
like, and then they'll work ban like DPS or Tank Pool.
But the other team was like banning all three supports, so I
was so confused.
And then Super Gomez was like, yeah, I just got banned from
his channel.
And I was like, why did you get banned on this channel?
I was like, what the fuck just happened?
We had two games with this guy.
What happened when those two games?
I was just so confused.
Yeah, Nostia Friendly Neighborhood Spider-Man.
I was like, what's going on?
Oh, it's a coin flip.
Yeah, batter's advantage!
Let's go!
Oh, wait.
For some reason, there was no music.
I was like, wow, that's a very quiet game.
I was like, wow, this game was still...
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Power swing.
All in.
Jesus Christ, never mind.
If I figure it out, my strat.
I go all in.
Every time.
And will I learn my lesson?
All in.
Let's go.
Coin flip.
Oh, he had pitch focus.
God damn it, I'm out.
play as the pitcher swing better better better swing okay
I'll grab that and then pitch focus there you go get out of
here okay going all in every time you'll eventually win guys
all in what was that six okay oh fuck never mind he hits
does okay it's fine we can if i still continue to go all in
it'll eventually work all right let's get that and pitch
focus that's a six there yeah it should strike him out
that's right get out of here oh he still makes the run okay
do fielding play oh eight how does guys that's not fair he's
He's paying the win.
She has a better set of cards.
He has all the limbs of...
Alright.
Five.
God damn it.
This is paying the win.
Oh, yay!
I won!
Okay.
Yay!
That's right.
I won.
This is pay the win.
That's right.
Absolute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Little baby batter.
Cat controller bladder.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right.
Winner.
Pay the win.
Dead cat saved you from pure skill.
I say yes.
I did.
know how i just went all in i told you guys if you keep
going all in eventually you'll win it all it works every
time and when it doesn't work it works every other time
that's where i cheesed it all right bend those lab
all right according to corny the entrance should be around
here somewhere
Boom.
I might double jump.
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait.
No, it's fine.
How the hell did those lunatics crawl out?
Oh, there's a cultist.
This is paid a win.
Togeep proclaim while swiping her debit card.
Okay, that shotgun is so OP.
attack oh well i have to parkour again nice an outhouse
that's a banging one like there i feel there's no other
point in using any other gun all right nice i got the cheese
all right take the elevator down and you can't beat them
join them what was that yukio card all the limbs With all
the limbs of that one card.
Where it's like an auto win if you play all of it.
Staby boy.
What exactly were you...
Exodia, yeah.
That's right.
Build my deck and have all the limbs.
I'll squeeze Zodia.
Oh, we gotta grab shotgun ammo.
Ooh.
What?
Oh shit!
I didn't think!
Oh.
It's fine.
Where's he coming from?
Oh my god, fucking Korshigra.
Oh.
Oh, that was easy.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Get out of here.
I have long range too.
I think I will have enough ammo.
Wait, he has a shield?
That's cheating!
Okay, if I don't look at him, and he doesn't look at me.
There you go.
We can play this game all day!
We can play it all day long!
I'm patient enough.
Just enough.
Yeah, that's cheating.
Follow the white cable, Jack.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
But it's all white.
This is not yellow paint.
You're gonna have to, you know, walk forward.
There you go.
You can't use that shield forever.
You're gonna have to walk forward sooner.
I'm patient.
I'll wait.
I have four cheese.
Any secret?
I knew it.
There's always a secret.
Gotta tailpick this.
Wait, what?
Oh.
There we go.
Pick up the cash.
Gotta use that to gamble more.
Wait, actually?
Wait, what?
I thought I could pick this up.
Is that not oil?
No.
Oh, it's not.
It's just...
It's just water.
Okay, more boomstick.
Alright, nice save.
Okay.
Turn that on.
Sorry, I bet you I only get paid like $1 after all of this.
Yay, secret.
Oh, yeah.
Now that makes sense.
The fire barrel.
It has a fire barrel.
icon on it that actually makes so much more sense oh fuck
now I'm burning where is he that's right who are you trying
to call was that it where is his teammates hello teammates
oh that was it it's just two guys guarding all of this not
Not very efficient, I will say.
By the letter of this here pack is the scientist agrees to
provide the lab, paraphernalia, and manpower.
The magician shall furnish the funds, sizable funds, and
jointly they shall investigate things unknown.
Results and revelation be shared equally.
Steve worked with scientists.
Old world scientists, no less.
Oh.
Old world scientists.
uh stevie what were you into i knew it i told you one of
three rats is a rat i can't run through the massive just cat
oh my god and they're a german rat no less my keep mine
keeps drifting back to betty they're so efficient enough to
make me show my work on the unknown bring her back it
wouldn't be some part of the trick in the memory lane no you
can't turn back the river can't unring a bell still if I had
chance to ask her one question the only one that ever
counted this rest is smeared with fondue oh no he was he was
stress-eating just want to be sure I there is anything I'm
missing out on what the fuck was that sound Oh, hat!
Hat kit.
That's so much ammo.
They are so like...
They're so generous with the ammo.
Or worse, a shrew.
What did I press?
Oh, I was supposed to look at that.
Oh, it's the ray gun!
Let's dip.
I got the ray gun.
The 1920s, the 30s ray gun.
How strong is that?
Oh shit, it's pure acid.
Alright.
Oh fuck!
He's throwing potatoes at me!
You know I'm gonna grab... Oh shit, I can't grab it.
Can I just...
What?
He can reach me!
Oh, I don't have ammo anymore.
I don't know if I like this gun.
I can just have shotgun.
I feel like shotgun is just so much more efficient.
Yeah.
If all else fails, my trust Shotgun.
There we go.
Yeah, no.
Shotgun's just better.
Like, I don't know why we get fancy with acid.
Like, just...
The good or reliable.
And we don't have to be fancy with the acid gun.
Which is the one gun and one gun only.
He has never disappointed us.
I knew there was one more.
Was there more shotgun?
ammo?
No, no, that's fine.
Armor get.
Ooh.
A varnish here.
Oh, that's the poison.
The acid.
Alright, I got that.
Got more shotgun ammo.
Is that it?
Alright, that turns off that door.
Want to be sure I'm not missing anything.
Yeah, why use acid when I have the good old feet?
The feet and the shotgun, the boomstaff.
I don't need...
You take a bite, they feel the burn.
Hit E to use it.
The pepper D.
What's that?
Oh?
What the fuck are you making?
I thought you were just a magician!
Oh, don't tell me I gotta get.
that running again what is all of this oh i get burned okay
yeah no he just dies automatically
yeah no he just dies oh that i don't mean to kick that
there you go there's still one more guy he's over there
That's right.
Call them to me.
It's just easier like that.
That's right.
Just make this easier for me.
Easy.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there's more.
Did I hit him?
Oh, I did not.
I got reloaded.
There we go.
Nice.
You like my movement, guys?
I told you.
I just need to adapt.
I told you I'd get the movement.
I'm doing the movement in my movement shooter.
It's so smooth.
Oh, my God.
It's so hard to find items because everything's just black
and white.
I'm so...
I'm so used to, like, registering color with, like, items
and stuff.
So it's, like, it's, like, trying to figure out where
everything is when everything is black and white.
Look, I'm so happy the enemies move.
If the enemies did not move, I would not see them.
I...
Finally, I came for the colorblind.
I'm so glad for movement.
I don't know if I can get up there.
That's somewhere I'm supposed to get there.
We need the only color in the existence.
Ah, this feels very boss room-like.
Oh, yep.
Now, what the absolute...
What is that?
What is the security system?
This costs...
Holy shit, this must cost at least $10.
Yeah, I'm like a...
Oh, like a dinosaur.
Oh,
reload.
He's going to do the combo.
Oh, window!
What you going to do?
That's a key, right?
I got the window on my side.
Reload.
Oh, shit!
in a different direction?
That's cheating.
What do you mean?
It changes directions.
There you go.
Oh my god, where's the glass?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, oh, no.
I have to use the ray gun.
She got me.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Oh my god, it's like jump rope.
It's like extreme jump rope right now.
Oh my god, extreme jump rope.
Oh shit, it goes faster.
Oh,
that's it.
That's after drink.
It's too extreme.
Alright.
Faster, faster.
Gas gas gas gas.
Oh, we did it.
We need all the ammo we can get stage girl All right, no, he
Who said that oh what the fuck was Eeyore?
What's this guy is a there's no wait a magician's salary
would not fund all of this Master
Please sir, I did not consent to this to whatever you and
that my magician friend have whatever arrangement you have
We are not the same He was a very successful magician There
we go Hello Igor, oh dear sir.
I mean master sir I did not consent to whatever role play
you have with my friend everyone someone's oh no no no no no
no no ever thought about tell me about okay who are you so
who the hell are you i'm egor egor not igor no egor why so
many yeah it's harder to pronounce as the classics would say
is he gonna get old real fast oh they must endure there's
plenty more where that came from oh no Igor imagine now
seriously who are you I'm the caretaker master or well I was
my former master's dokey bird gone like gone gone oh no no
just he's not here makes the lab a tad lonely apart from
What I was gonna say.
Robo assistance or that eerie creeping sense of
foreshadowing that somewhere along the way your cheese
brain's gonna get fried.
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, I was gonna say sir, can you please go back to
where...
No, no, no, no.
Go back to the thing where my cheese brain's gonna get
fried.
What do you mean by that, Igor?
Sorry, Igor.
That's not quite what I had in mind.
Please go go back to that.
You got any pointers suggestions This labs got crazy ridden
all over it.
Oh, it's milk toast compared to the labs in the old world
Believe me.
I know You're from the old world in a way, but master Bandel
took me in and taught me a thing or two Gave me a job too.
So here I am He's free housing too.
I bet he gives Dental business trip Yeah, you can say that
again Wait, I get it It's cheese because they're mine Well,
the word robot itself Comes from the famous play by Spam me
in etymology lesson I need facts, Igor No, no, master It's
Igor That's what I said No, you said Igor Oh, I had one more
R Sorry, it was four seconds Too many R's Oh, that's the
master's former assistant.
Oh, you are so lonely.
Betty.
Betty Lynch.
Not in the flesh.
Yeah, I'm going to say.
Flesh is weak.
But the master was quite devastated when his assistant left
him.
And then, well, oh my God.
He tried to rebuild her.
So he started building something to remind him of.
Oh, no.
Why didn't he have...
I was going to say.
why didn't that robot have legs don't judge well yeah i
guess still this one seemed unfinished we have the
technology unfinished so why did you give your your your sex
robot lasers probably deeper in the lab there should be an
update so to speak great just great extreme jump rope in the
it gets kinky guys it gets wild in the bedroom because it's
cool that's right extreme jump rope you can remove that lump
on your back it doesn't go down that road sir that would be
far far too much for them to handle are you have you check
the lump on your back oh which oh oh my god there's several
lumps on the back i'm gonna punch him at some point you're
still saying that out loud master oh right pretend i did
that so i'll be going i think it might be cancer i gotta do
visit more often master we can hang out anytime you want
It's okay.
You really need to get out.
You really need to get out and, you know, make some new
friends instead of spending time with the cancer lumps on
your back.
That's my suggestion for you.
He just wants friends.
He needs to see a doctor first.
That should be his first priority.
I don't like how I can't dash while jumping.
I might have got used to the movement in this game, but the
no dashes while jumping throws me off.
Rank up the projectors powers.
There's a fight here.
I knew it.
Oh, I should have thrown it at him.
Yay, cheese.
Oh, I thought there'd be like more of this okay more armor
anything else here oh there is I already have all of that I
have TNT I'll make sure I didn't it's all black and white so
it's hard to tell but I got to make sure I got everything
cheese to meet you I knew it I knew there was a fucking...
I knew there was a fucking thing to turn on.
There we go.
Anything else here?
That's it?
Alright.
Well, now I hold this.
This game looks pretty good.
God damn it.
What the fuck do I do with this?
Oh well.
There's a safe.
There it is.
Igor reminds me of me only nicer.
Oh, shit!
No!
God, though!
Oh, I saw a tap.
I got distracted.
Okay, I didn't jam it.
Thank God.
This is not one of the jammable ones.
I see it here.
Why can't I open this door?
I see you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
It's just slightly ajar.
We're trying to say, tell me to lose weight or some shit.
Like, let me in.
I can't open the fucking door now.
Classic.
It's not on the animation.
Like, it's not a different color.
Oh, yeah.
Like, the Scooby-Doo animation stuff where, you know, like,
you could open it because of the color of the animation.
The animation.
Let me in!
What do you mean?
I swear to God, if there is like something I'm supposed to
throw, I swear to God.
Oh my god, totally...
God damn it.
There we go.
My totally normal wall.
I fucking knew it.
Every time.
I don't understand.
Why can't I open this?
Is it just so rusty?
Why wouldn't I be able to open that one door?
And they're like...
Sorry, we forgot to add the animation budget.
Forgot to animate this one particular door.
Oh, it was up here.
God damn, I fell down.
Cartoon logic.
All right, I got another cheese, more acid.
Oh, that's a breakable box.
All right, I have to help pick this.
It's hidden.
Yeah, nobody oiled the hinges.
So you're not allowed inside.
Well, it's working.
Whatever it is.
Head back to the projector room.
Oh, yeah.
What the fuck?
Crazy frog.
Every era we have their own crazy fraud.
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
A hypnotoad.
Oh my god, they're sending toads to the brain.
Oh, no.
No head?
Oh, but it has arms this time.
Oh, does she have...
Have laser?
Oh, she has razor.
Jesus Christ.
He was kinky.
Oh my god, and cannons.
Oh my god.
What the fuck were you up to?
I don't like that sound.
Shit.
Okay, they explode.
I wonder if I can explode it myself.
I can't.
Oh, I can!
Wait, that's so convenient.
I could use it against her.
Wait, actually I might have to use acid for this.
Oh shit!
Oh, she got me!
Oh my god, I need that.
Oh!
She's slashy, slashy!
Oh my god, she's slashing me!
Okay, the acid's helping though.
Alright.
Yeah!
Oh fuck, I thought I was stuck.
First try.
Oh my god.
She slashed me up.
Okay, the acid is... I think the...
Oh god.
The acid is very strong against bosses, I would say.
what the were you up to after the war was not that bad i
turned out okay bro that guy got some into crazy after the
war the secret secret lab
oh my god now she oh wait there's What
the fuck?
I have to be closer to the kill.
Shoot him.
There we go.
All robots.
Like, what happened?
What happened to him?
Why are you like this now?
Okay.
See if there's anything here.
any secrets there is I don't know if it's a secret or if I'm
supposed to be here
oh why did the music change oh I'll just tank it it's five
oh shit wait there's more there we go Kobe Kobe Kobe!
Okay, Kobe!
Wait, I didn't get that one.
Oh, that's a sniper.
Oh, reload.
That's awkward.
There we go.
That should be everybody.
Alright, maybe I should not have tanked that.
I'll eat a cheese just in case.
Bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum.
Oh, secret.
Yeah.
Okay, it wasn't secret.
I had to go there.
Now, is this one of those more?
Alright.
A lockpick.
Nice.
Ever since I got those tail enhancements.
Plumbing repairs actually pay off.
Alright, one is over there.
Noink!
It's alright.
My friend's a millionaire.
He wouldn't.
miss this i had a lead a shaky one yeah but still a lead he
had a thing for i just thought i had a thing for landmines
don't judge don't damn what the fuck is betty can't be that
of a bad daddy what did betty do to you for all of this he's
like you'll never understand
Damn.
Betty was crazy.
The AI can't see me.
You should have programmed your AI better.
That's right.
The jiggle peeking is real.
Betty awakened some things in him.
God damn.
Betty was wild.
I'm gonna say there's no way, Betty.
Oh, shit.
I don't think I was supposed to go this way.
Wait, but there's heals here, actually.
Go that way just for the heals.
Watch me get electrocuted for getting the heals.
Reload.
Absolute.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Once you go, Betty, you can't go, Betty.
back what happened to you bro oh i was that was like oh i
did not realize that was just water oh hey money i missed
out on money
bro what happened to bros before host bro oh
this looks like the final stretch of that damn lab there's
gotta be some evidence here It's criminal that they made the
money black and white too.
It's like they don't want me to rob him.
What the fuck?
What shot me?
Someone behind me?
Oh,
shit!
Oops.
Thank God there's heals here.
That's awkward.
Give me a sec.
He's still alive?
He's got to jump over, right?
There we go.
It might not have been smart of me to run straight at the
sniper, but like it still got the job done.
And also me throwing the thing at myself.
I'm still alive.
He's dead.
the dead one I bet you there's gonna be a lot of mysterious
walls around like the totally normal walls around me and
I've missed like 20 of them I will not be
surprised hey where am I supposed to jump oh here oh secret
oh I was not supposed to jump here but I did it anyway it's
not fair The mysterious wall is also black and white.
How am I supposed to know?
Now this.
Even for Steve.
This is crazy.
Oh, this is now crazy.
Not the fucking two robot sex toys.
They're real to him, Toki.
They're not toys.
They're his life.
Oh, that looks like a boss fight.
Let me grab my acid gun.
I chased it, didn't I?
That's, that's, that's on me.
Oh my god, Steve.
Steve, you had three!
The only degree I got is a pedigree.
Why do you need three?
Hear me out.
Oh my god, Steve.
Oh my god, they have everything.
Oh my god.
They're like, they're, oh fuck!
Oh my god, Sieve.
I know I don't want to kink shame you, because you're my
bro, Sieve.
But Sieve, there is a limit to science.
Oh my god, what the fuck is the range of her feet?
Oh shit, that's way too fast.
I'm going to go reload my guns.
Betty can't be that good, Steve!
Doki, you don't understand.
I don't.
I don't understand, Steve.
I just think...
Oh, I could throw dynamite.
I forgot about the dynamite.
Oh, shit.
I'm just gonna stay here.
Oh, shit!
Where the fuck did he come from?
I might need HP though.
Oh, I should not have wasted that.
Alright.
Jesus, now there's plenty.
of oh
my god there's so many okay i gotta reload
what that's awkward
oh nice achievement get there we go there we go oh no i'm
called no you're not supposed to be humanized when i find
you we're gonna have a long talk about you a life choice You
and me both.
You and me both.
Nice achievement.
I didn't even know what achievement I got there.
See, I know I shouldn't kink shame.
But Steve, what the fuck?
Did you really need three?
Steve, what?
So Niki could run.
Papa, thank you for this.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Coast Guard arrival card.
scientist an average dockside arrival card three data three
years back please don't judge if you could build a lifelike
replica star scream you would too gordon thank you for the
super chat thank you yes but i would have built one i would
have built one
super chat thank you thank you imagine be a sip in the 30s
wild
bro i feel like in 1930s people get are like because you
don't have the technology yet i feel like in the 1930s like
the kinky stuff it's like even more wild back then just
because like technology they didn't have the technology yet
so they gotta get even more creative you know like wait
what's this what would these buttons have done did i like
cheese the game by not pressing any of them and just shot
her there must i must have cheesed like i get it i might
must have made it much harder than it needed to be
oh that's to leave those private friends were clearly
prototypes perfection takes time you know terminator thank
you super chat thank you thank you simple thank you with
super chat thank you thank you look doki robot girlfriends
don't talk back never leave okay oh it would have stunned
her during the jump rope oh see that guys i killed her with
skill i didn't need no cheese all right let's leave now I
got my clues.
I drive back.
I take the martini to the road first.
Where did that tree get there?
I get my martini first snack.
I get my gin and tonic.
I drive back.
Ba-da-bomb-bomb.
Back to my office.
Guess now you'll want a little update.
What now?
Oh?
Clip mop packing the payload, you promise.
Tired of flying blanks, we need a real bang.
We're looking for a longer barrel, a quicker release, or
just something with a little extra kick.
Swing by my workshop.
I've got a brand new piece of bang.
Genius, you don't want to miss out.
What was she thinking?
Oh, shit.
Upgrades!
Upgrades time!
Let's go.
I saved up all my money just for this moment.
Ooh, Vivian McCarthy.
Hello.
Are you out of your mind, Tam?
Announcing something like that.
Uh, uh, like, what?
That little notice you posted, banging, genius.
What kind of talk is that even?
It's about gun tuning, dummy.
Yeah, it's a what?
Bang!
Ballistics, augmentation, and no worthy game.
Oh, I didn't even think of that.
Jack!
It's because of the robots.
It's because of the Betty robots.
He's thinking about other things right now.
Jack!
More bang for your buck!
Huh?
What do you think?
Big ass nuke guns.
It doesn't quite...
Quite what?
No, no, no, but it's good.
It's good.
Great!
Even, uh... I'll use it like crazy.
Right now, in fact.
Young adults.
Shish.
Alright.
Boomstick, yes.
Increases damage.
All in.
I shall do these.
I'm going all in on the boom.
I'll get one of each for these.
Alright, nice.
I don't even need to look at the upgrade.
I just go all in.
Oh, it pierces.
Oh, shit.
Oh, alt fire.
fires three quick successful accurate shots oh wait there's
alt fires charges up and fires a more powerful shot how do i
use the old fire though all right charges up all right all
five fires sticky blob which explodes after deals area
damage okay area damage three quick accurate shots and then
fire more powerful shot that's good oh shiny I think it's
right clear it has to be right clear If you hadn't tossed Oh
shit Yeah, but that could be your new dad Yeah, but now I'm
a better dad It's like an upgrade I made my piece, okay?
I was just wondering Do you ever, you know Second guess it
Yeah, but I'm not deadbeat now Like your dad But now Maybe
not so much Well, things turned out okay right so whatever
yeah i get free upgrades your dad's in jail i think that's a
good exchange hey i bet you i'm a better dad than whatever
the fuck her old dad was like grab the comment a nerve to
die here can you imagine what filthy he whined about a but
good old 1930 racism he whined about drunk true spilling
i've seen a Shrew yet.
What do they look like?
Spilling string cheese hooch all over the carpets.
But one thing he said piqued my interest.
And not just one.
I stomach one filthy Shrew.
But he had a buddy.
Barely made it to the left.
And the smell, I tell ya.
Whoa!
Oh, I missed a lot of newspapers.
One of the older Mouse Bird Herald issued.
This one features a piece on suspected money laundering.
Oh my!
That's more than a few street magicians Cubs, cards, and
flat...
Mickey!
It was a different time.
Oh, is the bartender a shrew?
I knew it.
I knew there was something off about him.
Because I'm just role-playing, guys.
I'm trying to be immersive, guys.
I'm trying to be immersive.
the mouse seems to vanish into other pockets well according
to inside knowledge the police are on the move i've already
seen their first successes yeah we'll buy it all right do it
mercy why i need i don't care i'm gonna save my money i'm
gonna save my money and spend it all on this little kid oh
no he just scams me once need to the shotgun i let's see
animation so you can wrap.
Wait, how did animation cancel it?
I know I haven't prized these.
Oh, I didn't win 20 times.
Well, don't leave me hanging, Jack.
Did you see the secret lab?
Everyone get back, she's gonna be immersive.
Hold on to your tights, Wanda, because that place was nuts.
Robots, experiments, stuff I don't even have names for.
How the hell did Steve afford all that?
Oh, money, Jack.
The guy is still playing.
He was!
He fucking it took made me buy him shit in the army he did
try to uh recreate what the i let him i let him 10 cents she
used to be a stage girl before tinselborough snapped her up
right wait wait wait what do you mean recreate guessing her
accident hit him harder than anyone knew hard enough to
himself a robotic replacement that's ew well easy calling it
creepy is like saying wallet boys are just kind of into blue
cheese so what i was saying i knew it see we all see him as
a freak guys well this might be bigger than we first thought
i found traces of steve's dealings we're all keep shaming
him file group i think a bunch of weirdo mad scientist types
did you interrogate But they did leave a trail and she's
crazy cultists and what they were working on was out of this
world Oh, please sounds like more bandel smoke and mirrors
true crap No, this was something else eerie tail stiffening
Kind of stuff that makes my fur stand on then Wow, if it
rattled you Maybe there's something to it So what's the plan
now?
Not sure yet.
I need to think rethink even Go over all the clues I've got.
Maybe poke around elsewhere.
I'll keep in touch, alright?
Oh, you will.
I'll see to that.
Alright.
Can't believe.
See, we all think he's a freak, guys.
It wasn't just me.
Also, this just no...
This is the hardest difficult...
I think the moment I understood the...
The moment I understood the movement and, like, the feel of
the game, like, adapted to it, this doesn't...
not feel like super the hardest game mode the hardest
difficulty at all like i feel like i would if i was played
on normal i would definitely breeze through this even faster
all right i'm gonna refill i'm gonna refill my water real
quick guys i'll be right back
i'm back budge thank you the super chat thank you thank you
i don't want to be ashamed wrap it up dragons i'm casting
development of the robot token look it's fine if you want to
create a a robot of your deceased lover but he made three
like he made three why not just program all of it in one
robot what did he need three four it's solid many papa
neppers four and terminated thank you Thank you.
Two, maybe, but three?
Three backup.
If one was charging, he could have the other one.
It's another issue I wanted to talk to you about.
See, you're called a prototype.
I hope I will mislead you too.
It's not like that, Jack.
I'm simply concerned for our little brothers.
There's been some weird...
Disagreements?
There's two robo-dokies, so two is where I draw the line.
Guys, thank you for the super chat, Z.
Thank you.
Disinfectance?
No way.
They finally came up with something better than Spike D's
stuff.
Got it, patented it quick.
They're in real danger.
See, the shrews.
Oh!
of you know you know what the uptight and wealthy oh just so
anyway a little bird told me that the shrews are
disappearing faster than a shell's trench I also heard that
the police might be involved no one knows what to make of it
but maybe someone should someone with a a penchant for
solving mysteries so this is me to go and dig a little once
tired me see that's what i like about you jack i'll give you
a friend bonus too charge you three times to normal but
might check out lord gyro see the air is thicker than i
guess we aren't being greedy enough what about five what
would you do with five lord kerosus thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you all right got that unravel shmun
rival yeah it's kind of sus he is a politician though they
know all like they all need know all the insider knowledge
like the poly market thing you guys hear of the poly how
like there's an insider in the government because like he
keeps betting the correct things on poly market or some shit
i think he made like a hundred thousand dollars or something
strange type sniffing um about steve's lab rose symbols uh
vacant stairs cultists maybe question what do they want on
how do they get there no surprise he's like 11 oh yeah 11
for 11 that's their crazy eyes it's like the it's like oh my
god there's a polymarket bet right now where it was like
okay there's some crazy bets on polymarket where one was
like um what would be what would come here faster gta 6 or
the coming of christ it's like zero it was like you get like
very little money but i thought it was funny that someone
was like who would get there first jesus christ or gta six
and there's people that bet on jesus i smell as shrew as
conspiracy of foot and dr eureka thank you was super chat
thank you
never bet against jesus
Those are good odds.
Oh, hey.
Oh, he's just there.
I was like, hey, there's a snail.
I thought it was like an adventure time snail.
Alright, we depart.
Some crazy-ass bets going on right now.
Alright, clergy road.
It was time to stretch legs and peek into the row.
clergy row holly thank you for the super chat thank you oh
that's a shrew that's what that's what all shrews say what
did you do huh no lie we all know what you shrews do please
don't hurt me officer it was just a little cheese stick on
the sidewalk i ain't done nothing wrong oh yeah sure
Chokey, please.
Yeah, yeah, serve, protect all that.
No, no.
They're rounding us up.
Wham!
Paddy wagon rolls in and then gone.
Gone, how?
Gone, gone.
My buddy got nabbed for just being a shrew.
Okay, we've put up with that for years, but where it is?
He didn't vanish?
He just vanished?
Damn.
Damn, indeed.
Well, you watch your back.
I'm getting out of here to the wetlands or anywhere, really,
anywhere but here.
You.
Oh, shit.
I thought I was going to shoot him.
Oh my God.
Wait, I'm shooting cops.
Was it really a cop?
What the hell is going on here?
Wait, he wasn't.
Oh, it's fine, guys.
It wasn't an actual cop.
Guys, it's fine.
Guys.
guys it's okay it wasn't a real cop i didn't get her did you
just shoot him he shot first it was self-defense no he
probably had cheese on him probably is a cheese stick dealer
a real cop, guys.
It's okay.
Hello?
Oh, save station.
Is there a sniper?
No.
That's fucking right.
Come into my corner!
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
I'll blow up next to him.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that guy's tanky as hell.
Alright, we'll have acid burn him.
Ha ha, what you gotta do?
That's right.
Can't stop me.
Oh, what?
Carry badges.
But holy moly, they work more like mobsters.
Guys, guys, they're not cops.
He said they weren't cops.
Oh, I forgot about the all-fire.
I killed them anyway.
They're still so fast.
And they're like...
Alright.
Can I save him?
Look, if the game won't let me save him, what can I do?
It's not my fault.
The game won't even...
Guys, they're fake cop cars.
Wow, they're so immersive.
I didn't shoot a cop, guys.
They're fake cop cars, Chad.
They're not real.
I didn't commit no crime.
Save him, Doki.
Look, I, you know, I don't work for free, guys.
I didn't remember the, oh, I'm going to try it.
Oh, that's the outfire.
Okay.
Can I hold, hold it?
I wonder.
Oh, there's a shrew over there hello little guy oh no he's a
little guy oh it's just because he's a shrew right just
because he's true i'm not allowed to talk to him what the
actual cheesesteak what's going on district this nuts gotta
take a picture it's like me pulling up my phone so ugly and
crooked is the cops running it the fake cops is fast and i
need to get the cornelius pronto he's not worried about his
madness see even the game didn't want me to help the shrews
not my fault
okay i must be able to get across yeah i can
and then come out
i feel i don't know i think i like Whoops.
Oh hey, that's convenient.
I don't know if I like the ult fire, only because...
Only because I feel like...
I don't know.
The ult fire is weird.
Maybe it's good against the bosses.
Like when I'm...
I heard something.
No, there's nobody here.
You guys hear that, right?
Oh, maybe it's the cops beating up the shrews below me.
That's what I hear.
Maybe that's it.
Oh, use it for animation cancel.
Yeah, I feel like the charging of the gun doesn't do as much
damage as, like, just me fucking shooting it.
I feel like I do more just shooting.
shooting my gun.
Oh.
I opened that door.
Boink.
My money now.
Oh, secret.
The end of crime families.
When the older Malzberg Herald issues features a loud
six-page expose, but none other than Wanda Fuller.
A stellar example of investigative journalism.
This article, The Factor, brings down one.
of the massberg's mob family the world probably won't ever
be quite the same right oh my god news reporters actually
doing their jobs once you start you'll understand not from
taxes
oh oh that's a shrew watching me
all right let's save game
Yeah!
Look at me robbing a shrew.
Find the apartment key.
Oh, this seems like a boss fight.
Oh, it's not.
Boop.
Look at that.
Scooby.
Oh, shit.
It's Kobe.
It's finish time!
Boom!
Yeah.
Swipe.
Did I take damage?
No, I don't.
That's right.
Pop by the sailor map.
Wait, I take damage!
Wait a minute!
What do you mean?
I take damage!
Pow, pow, pow!
I should be invincible!
Like, what's the point?
Oh my god.
Okay, gun is more effective.
will, I want to say.
I think gun is stronger.
I'd rather just use my gun.
Punching was not as strong.
Let's see it.
Squeak eye, the sailor mouse.
A gun stronger than fist?
No way.
I think I could have killed these guys a lot faster if I
just used my shotgun.
Bring some Tyra I think Kashi is only better because it's
from Clergy Road.
Don't go getting clever with fancy schmancy fresh cheese.
Or the boys come knocking with your grannies.
You don't want that.
Now for the dough.
Papa, I lied to me.
I thought my body would be so jacked.
The bullets would just reflect off of me.
To be fair, they were punching me.
But like, they shouldn't be able to punch me.
They shouldn't be able to do anything.
water an eye and a spoonful of butter sift the flour onto
the pastry board toss a pinch of salt and a pitcher mix a
cup of hot boiled water the butter make a little crater in
your flour mountain crack the egg stir it in pour in the hot
water mix it up and knead with your hands when it cools down
work that dough is sincere like your granny's watching when
dough turns up elastic set it oh my guys it's just a fucking
recipe oh it is alright guys there's a recipe I'm gonna try
alright I want to see what animation can oh i see it all
right i can do the animation cancel i think i wanted to try
the animation cancel because you guys said there is one i
was like wait this is just a recipe because it is they made
me read a cooking recipe is there anything here oh i was
like which way is the secret and which way is the right way.
Now I can start cooking.
That's true.
Goink.
Come on now.
Oh my god.
Wait, that animation cancel is crazy.
No witnesses.
Did you guys see him?
He's striking in public.
That's against the law.
He was breaking the law, guys.
Worker strike in effect.
One of the older Malsberg Herald issues.
This one covers the troubling wave of worker strikes
spreading across the country.
Some blame it on grueling conditions in the munition
factories along with the effects of the quite big affair as
a whole others suspect is all just deployed concocted by
certain nefarious party Mossberg is not free from the bad
ink as the editor concludes in the articles
punchline oh my god another one despite these single-use
remote switch shoot it down to trigger it oh it's the it's
duck hunt wait are dogs real in the mouse world?
If there's dogs, then wouldn't there be cats?
You just shoot it down and trigger it.
Oh, it's this.
There you go.
Can't believe it.
Dogs are real.
I don't even have a chance to double tap.
I think I'll use that for more of a boss fight.
Let's see if I can get to the station without ending up in a
ditch.
I want to make sure there's oh hey you think they see me
whoops just casually shooting acid down yeah you saw that
didn't you yeah I don't be a fucking rat it's like oh my god
I just witnessed the crime Oh,
secret.
Oh, it's just money.
What's over here?
Now, the easy way, the quiet way, or the stinky way.
Wait, which one's the quiet way and which one's the stinky
way?
There we go.
Oh, no!
Alright, we gotta rob him real quick.
Say mouse bird.
Vote for BMP.
Don't hate them.
Replace them.
Oh my god.
I mean, at least they're not vanishing them.
Stop.
Why stop?
Why not make sure I get everything done here?
Okay.
Let me just shoot acid real quick.
No loot unturned, guys.
Gotta make sure.
This was the police.
You didn't see nothing.
You know what's good for you.
Oh, nice.
I actually needed that.
Oh.
Oh, it's just a normal window.
Riders, unite.
That's right.
You didn't see nothing.
Or you're going to turn out just like him.
That's why there's always no witnesses here.
I think that's everything.
So which way?
I guess the other way is the secret way.
And then that way is just me going straight in.
You know what?
More people to shoot at.
Here's Jacko.
There we go.
Burn that.
That's right.
If I just shoot the walls here.
Nice.
I guess the other way was like the sneakier way.
But I just like, fuck that.
I might as well just breach.
I'm here anyway.
Give me that money.
Oh, I can't get the money.
Breach, breach, breach.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum.
You take extra in the secret?
No, it's just money.
Okay.
Oh, Frundel.
Yeah, we're not doing it the lame way, guys.
You would think there'd be more cops.
Oh, oh my god, it's bulletproof.
Hey, you.
Stay in the trench coat.
Get me out of here.
I'm with the good cops.
Oh, I can tell the other ones about.
Oh, this one.
Okay, I was gonna say, like, which one?
That's the good cops.
What do I open this?
What?
I'm surprised nobody's stopping just everybody's just
letting me walk up here
I swear to God if I am missing some yellow paint right now.
There it is.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Where the fuck did this guy come from?
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Oh here
I might have burned myself a little bit.
Now you don't.
Okay, now I'm here.
Now I'm paranoid.
That guy came right behind me.
Prison key.
Where the fuck would the prison key be?
Oh, I could break through this one.
Okay, the other windows I couldn't.
have just went through this door.
Yeah.
Which door did I press?
I pressed something.
What the fuck did I press?
Hello?
Knock knock?
Oh, can I actually break this?
Zero to 35.
Exit only.
There's no way.
There's no way I'm supposed to think here.
This is a shooter game.
It's a puzzle?
I keep pressing it.
Maybe it'll turn on.
Oh, wait, there's levers.
Oh.
Oh my god, sorry, it's just the same color.
You would think that...
Oh, no.
Um...
But I keep pressing the 6.
It'll work.
It's because the levers were not white!
You know how they're like...
It's a different animation.
So I thought it was part of the background, guys.
I thought the levers...
We're probably in the background.
That sounded racist.
Or don't stop.
And not grab the key?
What the fuck did I grab?
I just pressed D.
Guys, what did I grab?
I...
Oh, one more?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, the other lever.
Alright.
Oh, minus two.
Whoops.
We just keep plus seven.
Plus seven.
Plus three.
Minus two.
Plus seven.
Plus three.
Minus two.
There we go.
It's just that easy.
Yeah!
Whoa, what the fuck?
That's us true!
I thought we were on the same side!
Thought we were on the same side!
What happened?
Oh shit.
There we go.
Double tap.
Okay, I got it.
What happened?
See, I told you guys.
This is why we arrest them.
Look at that.
Not loyal.
Not loyal at all.
Okay, I love the animation cancel for it.
I don't think the right click does much overall other than
using it to...
Alright, who's still alive?
Who is still alive?
Someone down there is still alive.
The...
Who is still alive, guys?
There's a shrew here that's waiting for me to...
Pop, pop!
Oh.
I never got the prison key.
But all of them.
Alright.
Get out of here.
I gotta make sure.
But I gotta save him.
Bada bum Opens from the other side Alright, I think we got
all the bad cops Look, look, we had to downsize Alright The
economy hit us hard Oh hey, I caught a blueprint And done
You're free Thanks man This place is a real madhouse The
officer upstairs Dirtier than the trash heap behind the
precinct.
Good to know.
So, I did just bust you out, right?
You gonna make a run for it?
Or, here's an idea.
Yeah, the budget got cut.
Uh, well, you know, uh...
Ah, yeah, forms.
We gotta fill those...
No, we can't get in.
Exit only.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
There's no...
I think I got everything.
All right, now I could save.
Well, well.
Times change.
Used to be a police station.
Now it's a police corporate office.
Yeah.
Back then we did real work.
How the fuck?
All right.
I can just wait until he burns.
I'm just watching it all happen.
Whoa.
Oh, shit!
I'm just gonna throw...
Oh, I wanted to throw the dynamite, but I guess we're here
now.
Oh my god, he tanked the dynamite?
He's not the look of a cop, but not the precincts think.
Damn.
All that... He literally...
He doesn't even need a bulletproof vest.
He is the bulletproof vest.
Yeah, there is money.
here so we're gonna grab that all right where's their
evidence locker too we gotta confiscate it
guys check making sure i'm reloaded everywhere
nice good cop strategy working pairs back them in a wall
don't leave you see see this is what i follow too don't
leave your work unfinished don't question their guilt, bring
them to justice.
That's right.
Look at that.
Good cop strategy.
That means I'm a good cop.
It's what I was trained to do, guys.
Map of Mouseburg.
Few mineholes and tunnels are circled.
A few.
Oh, we're gonna be in the...
Crooked cops were hauling shrews into the sewers.
Why?
No one could know.
Leon.
It's somebody's birthday.
Ooh, their first and last day.
Let's go.
A Tommy gun.
Oh my god.
He gets a Tommy gun for his birthday present?
What the fuck was my birthday present?
When I was in the police precinct.
Oh my god, make sure we got to steal Leon's stuff.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's...
the reference leon kennedy it's resident evil no no james it
was a different time back then
well i was gonna say why the can't i press this
okay i just want to make sure i'm not missing anything all
right is it an actual good gun or am i going back to the
boomstick the boom boom
I reload.
Reload.
Yeah,
no.
Old reliable.
The old reliable.
I knew it.
Back to the meta.
there you go i'll use it for that though just because you
know what since we're here anyway
i love the animation cancel
where are they coming from oh shit
what all right let's is that sniper
that was a sniper
that should be everybody easy oh my god full arm and health
too that's everybody I bet you watch
so predictable look at that triple oh my god quadruple kills
All right.
Don't worry, he has to stop.
Easy.
Get predicted.
Level design.
I've been here before.
Look at that.
That's how you play video games.
I didn't go to the park.
Is that fine?
I was gonna sit.
Wasn't there something over here?
Yeah, because I didn't go this way.
There might be stuff here that I didn't get.
Oh, it's just army.
Oh, that, you're so confident.
There we go.
Bro, I killed your entire precinct.
Oh, there's just nothing here.
Oh, it was just a trap.
Really?
You're just gonna set up two mice there for your trap?
I killed like ten people back in the road.
Eh.
Tommy is decent, but I think the acid gun...
The acid gun is just better.
I think a Tommy gun is just more so like, when I have
nothing else to use.
Oh my god, the moth is back!
Get out of here!
Get out!
Oh no!
So he added it up.
He's like, I'm trying!
Get out!
I'm batting you towards the outside!
No, not there!
No, I'm missing the lord!
I was in too deep.
Way deeper than I signed up for.
Get out!
The word I'm listening, go this way!
Right?
No!
Oh my god, I flew back!
How are you still here?
Guys, what lore am I missing?
Ah!
Well, that was awful in more ways than one.
Gotta fill everyone in.
How are you still alive?
There's nothing to eat!
Washing him Wow.
Oh, what can I do to...
Oh.
I don't know where it went.
It was gone for two days and now it's back I have no clothes
in here but I tried I opened the door for him he wouldn't
even fly to the door they even fly to the door I don't even
know where he flew to oh please don't get near me oh solid
thank you super chat thank you Thank you, my whole she's
losing a 1v1 against a mop.
Okay.
What's up, Jack?
Need a drink?
Yeah, I do.
I just fought a mop.
I got a new case.
The mop lives here now.
Yeah?
What is it?
Apparently shrews are disappearing from their hood, like a
cheese grenade.
One minute there and poof, the next they're going.
Yeah, wouldn't be the first time, Jack.
No, sir.
smaller ones fault.
Maybe they just grew too big.
What do you mean?
Well, it's Shrew thicket all over again.
Didn't I tell you that story before?
Ah, you're gonna need a refill for this one.
I certainly will not say no.
The drink's on the house, but the story comes with a price,
my friend.
I'm a working Shrew.
I'm happy to fill your glass, but my younglings need their
supper.
You don't have kids John well you don't even have a wife
anyway shrew thicket ah those were the days we did it Jack
carved out a little slice of shrew heaven here on this very
soil ran legitimate businesses real honest work judges
bankers coppers businessmen we had them all all of our own
ink nice homes families all that jacks what happened so what
happened there is a scale in this world jack invisible but
it's there measures us all when you're a little wrong when a
shrew and a mouse get together though do you make like a
middle midsize one but real that you'll outgrow yourself
reach places you never thought you could and in this world
interspecies your tail just because they can so they clip
and clip they mean a shroud at the bottom and there ain't no
shrew thicket anymore oh maybe i'll pour myself one oh no
he's having ptsd from shrew thicket all right i go back to
the board oh new arrival wait are there any comic strips i
knew it i know it then but next day was about to smack me
right in the face pow well it's mouseburg you can't take a
stroll without catching a swing but me i'm no swing guy i
stick to jazz i thought he was just gonna shoot him i
thought that's what he meant all right we got new upgrades
new upgrades
I don't I'm going to get the acid I feel like the acid is
better A better investment I'll do one upgrade Alright
Sprint Rapidly dump at the cost of a water spread Oh sorry
the James gun
You like jazz
Alright we can go to our office now
Alright save Let me put on some new clues.
He wrapped and they're not going to jail.
The shrew shortage.
Something's right in the precinct.
The violent cops aren't just cracking down.
They're locking up the good members of the force too.
All right.
In the sewer.
Everything's adding up, guys.
It's all coming together now.
Did you find anything of substance?
Not sure you want to hear this, Cornelius.
bad huh worse the cops they were rounding up their shrews
not an arrest or two more like a district-wide hunt what
yeah but these weren't your run-of-the-mill trigger happy
cheese chewing law biting cops something's rotten in the
police force stinks worse than blue cheese on a hot day
you're saying these police were dirty dirty cops in the
1930s they've been locking up their own wobble to keep the
honest cops from squeaking and the shrews they lock them up
too not that i can not my 1930s must be holding them
somewhere else impossible now you're telling me racism
exists too the mock is next on my list oh all right to the
sewers echo true this is most concerning this poor little
rodents poor rodents he needs their votes guys
He's got to save them.
Their votes matter.
Not women.
I'm not joking.
I'm joking, guys.
I'm just being immersive.
I'm just getting into character.
Guys, I was just getting into character.
Okay.
I got into the sewers now.
Wait, what's over here?
This house is open.
The roadhouse.
Oh, it's another speakeasy.
Whoa!
Bang!
Oh, it's like its own little upgrade area.
What the fuck?
Can you imagine?
Oh, it's another baseball area.
All right, let's leave.
It's where you play legal baseball cards, I guess.
The underbelly was crawling with lice.
Or maybe mice.
Nice.
Good old 1930s when you just leave a shotgun in the trash.
All the grime from up top wash-down here.
And if I wanted to find the missing shrews, I had to push
through.
all right we'll just what the fuck how is you still alive
there we go all right nice come on i know you're there
oh my god all right oh i don't have ammo all right oh my god
He's almost got me.
There we go.
Alright, maybe it's not too bad.
Oh my god.
The fucking spread for that.
For the triple.
Of course that hits me.
Alright, maybe the James gun is not as bad as I thought it'd
be.
It does help in close quarters.
Alright, nice.
We'll go.
Yeah, I knew there was loot here.
Wait, can I get there?
There's so much loot over there.
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Miss.
There we go.
Where are they?
Oh, cheese luggers.
Here than a midnight raid on a dairy truck.
Yeah, something smells cheesy right now.
I mean, right.
Oh, what's that sound?
I guess, oh, that's a car.
I need a key for this.
Whoa.
Oh, give me a sec.
Oh, fuck.
I keep forgetting I have no acid.
Yeah.
Let's get double-dinked.
Get animation cancelled.
That's right.
Goddamn sweaty try hide.
Alright, there's no fake wallace.
Just right for a shrew.
What's the hat?
Just a hat, but shrew size hat nonetheless.
Can't be more solid proof of shrew trafficking!
Where are they taking them?
Shrew racket.
Time to find someone higher up.
Wait, he lives those?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
There you go.
Nice.
Alright, any more?
I got more of these coming for you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, now I'm more acid.
There you go.
That's why I should have keep closer.
Easy.
my life.
And I need to make sure I'm...
Oh my god, it's all black and...
Oh, there was an anvil there.
It's so hard to see how the fuck was I supposed to know
there was an anvil in there.
Yeah, I think I got everything.
We go here now.
Alright, got my typewriter.
Yeah, shout out to that Dragoon that told me about the
animation cancel.
It's putting in some work right now.
Oh, what the fuck?
Not the smartest henchman.
I swear to God, if a train comes over the moment I said
that, that seems like...
I wonder if that's foreshadowing anything.
I...
I wonder.
Hmm.
Oh my god, they shoot back.
I think this is a Tommy gun angle.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, that's what it's for.
They're still shooting.
Oh my god, wait, was that dog?
Oh, no.
Oh, wait, you can headshot with the James gun.
actually.
What's that for?
Oh, whoops.
Burn myself.
Oops.
Just casually burning myself.
Eh.
Oh.
Sniper over there.
Where do I can?
I got him?
There we go.
Oh God.
There it is.
Wait.
There he is.
Oh, there he is.
Where is he flying to?
Where are you?
Oh, my smoke detector.
Okay.
There he is.
All right.
We'll let him chill there.
We'll let him chill there a little, I guess.
I don't think I will.
I'm as convenient that.
Oh!
There you go.
You've been swinging for hours.
Like, where could she be?
That's fucking right.
Whoa.
A triple tap.
That's right.
I could just jump over you.
Sucks to be short.
It's like, we're gonna get And I was like, what if I just
jump over this?
Oh my god, there was an Anvil the entire time.
Oh my, there's an Anvil here as well.
Let's see.
Wait, there's shrew trafficking.
How come they let these shrews work with them?
Some shrews are just better than others?
There's no way.
They're all shrews.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, I didn't sit.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, my god.
I'm stuck here.
Okay.
There you go.
Headshot.
I didn't say anything!
I didn't say anything, guys!
Okay, I need to know...
Oh.
He's still alive, but there's like the battle music stop.
Okay, this is where I'm supposed to go.
Try and make sure I'm not missing anything.
I swear to god the fucking moth comes down.
I swear to god.
Oh, what the fuck?
What are you doing here?
Where did he come from?
Nice.
Got a heal too.
Maxed HP now.
Okay, so that means this area.
Wait.
There we go.
Try to make sure no stone unturned.
Where did that come from?
Alright, here.
Might be stuff here then.
A fucking course.
Okay, there's nothing here.
Fake wall!
God damn it!
Not again!
God, these goddamn fake walls!
They keep jukeing me.
Where was it?
Which room?
I'm so lost!
It's always these goddamn fake walls!
Oh my god, I see it.
The totally normal wall.
I see it now.
Oh no, now I've burned myself.
We gotta wait.
Ooh.
Secret.
Charming spot.
Just the right amount of abandoned and possibly haunted.
Haunted.
Don't like that.
The mouse bird stinks.
I think Riverdale sucks.
That's it?
That's it from the secret?
There's no way.
Just five.
Oh, wait.
There is.
There is a way.
Let's see.
Just five dollars?
How is there more to the secret?
Oh, that is just it.
I think cool of this sucks.
What the fuck is the secret?
Oh, there it is.
And I'm timed, too, for that.
At least the timer is super generous.
Nice.
60 bucks.
For all of that.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
I keep thinking I have...
Where am I?
I can't see!
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Where is the door?
there it is.
It took me into the corner.
Oh, it was a trap off for $60.
It was a fucking trap all along.
There we go.
I just can't see shit.
The fuck's the door.
It's $60 and $60.
out
i got more acid too which is nice i know i left some health
pots somewhere
i know there were a ton of health pots oh there it was one
there's another all right we can go now that's like watch me
drink your health pots
okay where are these guys all right it's just one guy
There you go.
You know what?
You deserve that.
Get my TNT.
Go up.
Bring anything up?
Alright.
Nothing up here.
More flashlight shit.
Oh.
Have you like, got the money?
There's something I'm missing?
There's like...
How do I get?
Oh wait, there's a door.
I was like, how do I I get in this tiny hole, I say as the
door was right next to me.
You don't understand.
It's blocked.
And nice.
Ooh, it's quiet.
Too quiet.
Enemies are going to show up any moment now.
Alright, I should.
There you go.
I should power.
it on.
Parkour.
Oh, thank god there's paint on that board.
I want to know what to do.
It's going to stop eventually, right?
I'm going to jump across this.
Oh, side jump.
It's just that easy.
Anything over there?
No.
Hello.
Knock knock.
Bye.
Yeah, no, I'm not wasting a shotgun bullet on a shrew.
Are anybody else?
It's like, who shot that?
What the fuck?
Why are they below me?
Oh!
Here we go.
That's good.
We're alive.
Whoa.
Now, no.
It's because I meant in a way where they're so easy to kill,
I don't need a shotgun because they're so they're like
glass.
They're made of glass, guys.
Joki, you don't need to defend yourself.
a waste if I use my shotgun bullet, because I can get the
job done with a regular bullet.
Kobe.
Oh my god, wait, he's still alive?
There's no way.
The last stream, rest in peace.
I'm trying to save ammo here.
Oh my god.
But I know there was one more.
Nope.
Just the acid.
Fuck it.
Oh, that still hits.
Let's go.
You know what?
Tommy gun time.
James gun.
Whoa.
Alright, head glitching.
I'm head glitching it.
That's right.
Apex taught me that.
What's that sound?
There's some... I hear it.
I hear some buzzing.
I thought there's like hidden stuff, a secret room here.
Oh, there is.
It's not really a secret.
It's where I'm supposed to go.
Bum, bum, bum.
I'm in your vents.
Oh!
Not bad guy.
I can talk to him.
I have on the hardest difficulty.
I know it doesn't seem like it.
I just asked for tickets.
And they gave me a knuckle sandwich instead.
Tickets, please.
I don't rough up people for no good reason.
Cheese leggers, though.
Plenty of reasons there.
Yeah, like walking around with no tickets.
And in those filthy, briny overalls.
sure wait briny like they took a swim in pickle juice or
salt water must be a sewage use they're running I see say
where'd your dance partners run off to hard to tell being
too busy seeing stars since they left but if I had to guess
I'd say they're running their racket further down the canals
a lot of movement a section that's supposed to be shut down
oh and watch out for their foreman he's got a nasty snap
duly noted thanks say you wouldn't happen to have a ticket
on you oh my god don't push your luck bob he has a problem a
ticket problem yeah there's something in the seawater it
might be at the docks it always happens on the docks okay He
did not tell me they're fucking Thousands of criminals down
here, too But, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump All right, it's
just two, guys
Whoa, whoa Oh, my gosh, the flies I was like, who's shooting
me?
It's the mouse flies See, this is why See, I told you, look
at that, this is why I don't Waste the shotgun bullet on
these guys
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's just all of them.
I am so fucked up right now.
Oh my god, where's the sniper?
Okay, can I shoot him from here?
I think I can.
Whoa.
Oh, shit, he's here!
There we go.
All right, we made it.
There we go, we made it.
I should have just threw an acid thing here.
I don't think I was meant to just stay here.
I held my corner.
I was like, my corner.
I was absolutely supposed to move around.
Last man standing.
I stand my ground.
Yeah, I was supposed to walk around.
I was like, hmm, that's a lot of mouse bodies.
It worked, though.
It worked.
I stood my ground.
There's something up top.
I wonder if I can get there.
I knew it.
Exactly.
Why go to them when they can come to me?
Wait, actually, this This might actually be better than the
pistol.
Well, you guys are right.
The James gun is pretty OP.
Because they take headshots, too.
Is there anything here?
Hello, anybody home?
Aw, fuck.
Are you...
Oh, it's a crocodile?
The Gator?
A giant Gator in the sewers with a gavel gun.
You better believe it, bub.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, he is suppressing fire right now.
I mean, he's just gonna be...
I could just go around him.
What's he gonna do?
Church.
This is the boss fight of...
Oh, shit!
There's gators on the water!
Alright, now I was gonna say...
Oh, man, it's easy.
I can just...
I was like, who would have thought?
Fucking knew it.
Alright, that's the only one left.
Oh, my god!
The goddamn baby gators!
Come on!
I'm trying to make sure there's no baby gators around here.
Oh my god, not the baby gators.
Not the baby gators!
Alright.
Wait, what is he drinking?
We're, oh shit, not feeding time!
Okay, I gotta get rid of the baby gators.
Okay, one more bullet and a dream!
Okay.
Okay, reload!
Wait, is he healing?
There's no way, that's illegal.
Oh my god, I could have done this.
Oh shit!
Whoops!
Oh fuck!
It's alright.
I fire on my side.
There we go.
Alright, let's keep burning him.
Easy!
Why did you kick?
I couldn't help it.
It was so kickable.
All right, I have no more ammo, though.
I only have, like, 17 bullets to my name.
All right.
Nice.
I think I was supposed to just use the explosives.
But I got too cocky.
What's this?
Mad friend.
killed his brother.
He jumped, crouched, and flew away.
Oh.
By revving my... Oh, I can fly now!
But I learned to fly?
I got my flying license.
How do I use it?
Control to glide.
Oh!
Nice.
Oh, I didn't kill him.
He's just sleepy.
Know what I use it though?
Like here I guess?
Oh here.
Ooh.
Remember there's stuff up there.
There's money up there.
I want it.
Money is money.
Fuck I just broke these.
I don't even know how parkour that though.
Yeah, I don't reach it.
Wait, unless...
No, I can't reach it.
I can't jump as high as this, unless...
Unless there's like a little anime.
But I got crushed up.
I got crushed up, dokey.
No, I don't think I can.
Must be a way though.
Wee!
I can glide.
I need to speed up that, though.
Oh my god, there's so much money up here.
No, I can't fly up.
There's, like, a little thing here that blocks me from
flying.
But no mouse should have flown before.
TNT jump.
Just rocket jump.
It's that easy.
Oh.
Whatever, I'm not gonna bother.
Bye, money.
Goodbye.
Can't believe I have to leave money.
For the first time ever.
I was just...
I guess I was to teach the mechanic.
But is there something down here?
Oh, no, nothing.
Okay.
A tragedy.
Those coins will have no family now.
Want someone please think of the money.
They'll have no home to go to.
Journey.
Okay.
Save station.
Totally normal wall.
That's what they all say.
Is there something over here, then?
If I'm supposed to go here?
No.
Parkour time.
Whee!
Wait, there's something over here.
Yay!
I robbed them!
Let's go!
Where is...
Where am I?
There we go.
Nice.
Made it.
it by oh 20 enemies oh by throwing and kicking nice oh yeah
i didn't even have to waste my bullets on them oh fuck okay
me oh there's no ammo
oh they're not close enough
jill go peeking that's right that's what apex taught me i
think it's that's not how you're supposed to play this kid
this is a movement shooter this is a dokey shooter now all
right i gotta go down here i'll make sure i don't miss i
knew it there was money you're trying to hide money from me
I'm flexing on these AI.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck, no.
Get out of here.
Oh, I don't have ammo anymore.
God damn.
They have numbers.
What am I supposed to do against that?
They have the numbers advantage.
Yeah.
Oh
It's so annoying Because I would like oh my god, I would use
I would like crouch jump and everything But like all the
glide is so annoying
Actually, I don't know if I like the glide I might I'm gonna
try to see if I quit I might be able to to it's fucking up
my movement it's my movement tech i i had my movement tech
down okay telecopter yeah i got rebuying it there you go put
it here
there you go there we go
all right i bounded it i bounded it to to my mouse button Oh
my god, that actually fucked with me so much because I was
so used to slide jumping.
So the control, I kept trying to slide jump, but I started
floating.
I was like, that ain't right.
That ain't right.
I think I was supposed to shoot it and then...
What was that gonna do?
No?
Yeah, I was supposed to shoot it and then it would, yeah,
but then I just jumped over it.
I- Speed run!
Speed run tech!
I was like, oh, why are these bins?
I mean, I could just jump over it though.
It was much more efficient.
Wait, what?
Yes.
No.
Oh!
What?
Why?
Why did it tell me to change my resolution?
Why does he keep telling me?
I'm just trying to save my game.
Oh, no, that bugged my thing.
I didn't...
Was it at 2005?
Whatever.
No!
Oh!
Yeah, but I already re-binded it, so I was, like, confused.
What the hell?
Vashbap, we have to deal.
All right, we'll come back soon.
You talking to me?
Wait.
Which one is the actual place I'm supposed to go, though?
Huh.
Oh, was that 1080?
I was going to say, like, did I...
Was it here originally?
I don't even know.
I definitely didn't click any of this.
Wee.
Okay.
I wouldn't want to combust that though.
What's the plan here?
To here?
No?
Why did I have to activate this?
Huh.
And there's money here.
Follow the yellow page.
Oh,
fuck.
Oh, wait, what?
There was stuff in the water all along?
What do you mean there was...
Whoa, whoa, okay, okay.
That actually scared me a little.
Oh, no.
Be here?
Oh.
There we go.
Yay!
Oh my god, I didn't even know you could, like, go
underwater.
I was like, ew, sewer water.
But still, why do I have to go here?
Like, what's up here?
Is there anything supposed to be up here?
Or was that just bait?
Was that just bait, guys?
So why did it make me fly all the way up here?
For the coins?
Oh, it might have been for the coins.
Eh.
Oh, you saw it?
Was there a fake wall?
God damn it.
It's always a fake wall.
God damn always a fucking fake wall.
Where is this fake fucking wall?
Oh there it is.
There it is.
Oops.
Oh my HP.
Oh it's a funkel pot.
my mini me but I was still trying to find my meat all right
I don't even know what I'm too paranoid to say yes I'm
gonna have to stab my ground again that's got to be the big
bad foreman kind of scrawny for a boss more like mini boss
all right where where are the enemies
Why?
Why is it so quiet?
I don't like this.
Oops.
I didn't see the icon.
I thought I could surprise him.
No.
You're not one of them coppers.
Of the crooked kind.
No.
unfortunately and whatever this operation is it's a stinky
sticky roadblock in my way so this ends one of two ways
you're in cuffs or you're on the ground either way you're
that's right wait wait wait we're just transport outsourcing
oh outsource that's what the boss told me to say yes may
ain't our job to ask questions we just deliver it's them
cops Real rats, I told you!
One out of three!
I told you!
They made us do it!
Swear on my mama's cottage curds!
One out of three rats is a rat!
I'm guessing you're ferrying the shrews up the shore.
Up, up!
Somewhere in Wallop Bay.
Ain't got an exact spot.
The cops take the cargo over by the sewer outflow.
Their shrews...
not cargo we we my bad sir while the bay is huge it's like
looking for a shrew in a haystack i need to head back to the
office rethink everything i've learned preferably over a
glass of spicy hot fondue oh there's gonna be an ambush now
that's why there's so many fucking oh there it is the door
closed there you go there it is cut There it is.
Okay, nice.
I do have acid, too.
What did not work?
There you go.
What did I drop to?
All right, I got the...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, they live, like, in the doghouse.
I see what you did there.
What the fuck did you pick dynamite?
Oh, no.
It's bugged.
I gotta say, I did not pick the Don of my options.
Are you really serious?
There we go.
Jacob peeking, Jacob, oh, oh, where did he go?
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, oh
reload.
You live that?
You take the shotgun, pull it?
Oh my god, there's so much more.
Oh my god!
There we go.
Oh shit, not me in the drop there.
We're fine, we're okay.
See, I thank Kobe this.
Watch this.
Kobe!
Where did it go?
Wait, did my maid go?
Kobe!
Alright, no, I don't think I can hit that.
Never mind.
Head glitching?
Let's go.
Oh, God, it's next to me.
Oh, God, he's next to me.
Oh, God.
Just chilling on the water.
Right next to me.
Okay, maybe I can swat him to the door like i don't mind if
he's outside like if he's like out my side my pc room but i
don't like how close he is i i do not it's just because he's
too close i don't want him to touch me it was clean too
clean and clean made me nervous oh god oh god i don't like
that i don't He's too close.
Oh, he's too close.
Give me an HP real bad.
Oh, I'm, like, looking at him.
I'm just looking at him right now.
Oh, look.
My car is here.
Wasn't there, like, something that opened?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, can I use this water?
Is there a maze here too?
Oh my god.
I like fucking left all the sewer water because I was like,
oh gross sewer water.
I'm just staring at it now.
Now I'm paranoid.
I'm like, what did I miss?
What else did I miss in the sewer water?
Eh.
Am I missed up here?
No, thank God everything.
Alright.
Sayonara.
I go back home now.
God, he's just sitting there.
He's just sitting there on the wall.
Messingly.
How do we name mops?
It's gonna die soon.
Mops don't live that long.
I just don't want it to die in my room.
I just...
It's not the thing that's super shiny.
they thank you
same as always you come down to my investigation skills i
tend to do wield him from time to time ah yes my trusty fist
do i need to buy these on a mouse the paper spins a
fantastic tale of betty lynch's extraordinary life though
it's unclear if any of its true as a prelude to her big
break the upcoming badness show the author wonders if her
string of misfortune sharpened her acting skills or maybe
it's her talent that brought their hardship in the first
place like am i gonna spend my money on anything else is my
money just spent on like collectibles
only found one
all right is there any money i could talk to see no talking
prompts oh cornelius wait where was he oh there he is Jack!
Over here, is it, Sport?
How's life treating you, Corny?
Oh, you know, speeches, rallies.
It's tiring work, but important, and nonetheless.
Well, I'm more interested in your thoughts on the case.
Did you learn anything about those poor missing shrews?
I did, for a change.
They were taken down into the sewers, ferried away by a
bunch of cheese leggers.
That's horrid.
So, did you find them?
Return safely to their homes, I take it?
Truth be told, I'm hitting the wall here.
Gotta think this through, double-check my findings, maybe
poke around other cases until something clicks.
I see.
See.
Well, I'm sure you'll bounce back in no time.
Let me know if you have a stroke of a genius, Morton.
If I have a stroke, Cornelius, I'm calling the doctor.
I'm just, I'm always looking.
If you see me turn around here, really far, I'm looking at
him.
I'm looking at the bomb.
He's just there.
I'm waiting for him to fly right now.
It's only a matter of time.
Okay, got that.
I knew it.
I knew we were heading to the docks.
Tied the shrews.
round up.
Much of nasty cops are leading a shrewd trafficking
operation.
Alright.
We're going to the docks now.
It was a day like any other until... It's the dame!
Every time there's a woman!
A sexy woman oh my god and she's showing ankles oh my god i
saw her voice the moment she walked through the door wrapped
in makeup and a cloud of perfume reserve she definitely got
a tail job no that voice not a contralto the contralto thick
rough like gorgonzola becante slept on her Oh my gosh, she's
French too.
A wee wee.
That's me.
Vivian McCarthy.
Bonjour.
No, that's down the hall.
Tis like hello.
Only...
On Francaise.
Welcome you permanent resident of Yuma.
Mark Dignan is super chastised.
They can thank you.
Oh, you are no fun, Mr. Pepper.
Tisk.
I have a job for you.
I don't need any more headaches right now, so if you don't
mind.
Nonsense.
You're drowning in death, picking up small fries and petty
cases.
What you need is a big one.
How big?
And this, Mr. Pepper, is the big one.
Oh.
And what's the deal?
It's about my friend.
she's dead they killed her jack murdered her they well it
sounds like you already know who they are the lumps on
ecore's back please mr pepper it's a figure of speech bet
she's friends with betty oh i understand now i understand
simon beautiful talented a radiant star destined to bask in
the
nuffed out that shining star just like that yeah i know she
must be wild now i know closed on her forever mr pepper
that's all very theatrical so they killed her it was no
accident i did a few movies myself back in the day but that
doesn't matter to me anymore betty does she was a close
friend and they the whole poisonous industry killed her
quite an accusation lady.
Talk on the street is this was an accident.
I told you it was big.
The biggest.
So please, take the case, Mr. Pepper.
Start snooping around the film studios on Tensel Avenue.
You'll find answers there.
I'm sure of it.
And trust me, I pay good for the right intel.
All right, I'll take the case.
But I don't come cheap, Mrs. Or is it Ms. Oh, she's single,
guys.
Can't wait to build three Vivian bots after this.
Got hit my homie up.
I'd be like, I understand now, bro.
I...
Could you also build me three Vivian bots?
Oh, my gosh.
She's single, too, guys.
We're so
all right i've seen the light i understand now simon i'll go
to the hollywood studios steve is redeemed why stop that
you're so right the world's my oyster after this case i've
all the money in the world to make more than three oh
tinseltown tinsel avenue that was not familiar your game.
Glitch glamour and now murder looking to steal the
spotlight.
Alright.
Holy shit!
Okay, I did not expect like an entire army over there.
Alright.
Let's grab some loot real quick.
The extra loot.
No, I understand now.
I know why.
my bro needed to build three
oh that's a big gun oh my god
I'll just wait this can burn them oh shit never mind I'll
just like I'll just wait okay
nice all right there is a lock there He still got me?
How?
I unlocked a shortcut.
Oh, shit!
Oh, I'm one.
He should be dead.
I did not expect him to be right next to me.
Oh?
Why is there a photo?
There he is.
Chuck Flake.
up blue cheese what's this doing here well well okay so
that's where i have to go in color what is this i have to
play this in black and white what do you mean in color what
is this new fangle technology wait a minute that's illegal
God damn new-ass technology.
Here's the...
Black and white films will be here forever.
I want to make sure I got everything.
What?
Ah, mobsters.
Of course.
I don't gotta...
I'll launder money somewhere.
Oh, he's dead.
Hey, money laundering.
I'm gonna grab the cheese.
I've been hoarding a lot of them.
Color in this economy.
I know, right?
Oops.
The mouse hit my keyboard.
Wait, can I break that?
I knew it.
What the fuck?
Oh, I think it's from me breaking that.
Yeah, I should kill him, right?
God, Gabba, do cool!
What the fuck?
He got but good all over.
Yeah, my bullets faster.
Ooh, why did the music got a little tense there?
Oh, that's why.
There we go.
What?
That hit me?
That one fucking bullet.
Like you said, Gabagoo.
Oh, I actually Oh.
Chili bucket.
Oh, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Okay, it's fine.
I hear them.
Speeding somebody up on the other side.
Alright, we got the shortcut.
Wait.
Oh.
Whoops.
There, that should kill him.
It's like an acid shot and a an acid shot and a shotgun.
Yeah, I knew.
I knew they were there.
There we go.
Get out of here, little guys.
This ain't for you.
Oh, what's the surprise?
Mouse barrel.
You never expect a rat in a barrel.
Let's just be here.
Like, what is he gonna do?
Oh, and I'll carry this up.
Ooh, armor.
Grab armor real quick.
Chuck it down.
And then I wait.
Oh, oops.
Got one last shot in the road.
There we go.
Oh, there's the little guys.
That should be all of them.
Easy.
Look at that.
So nice of them.
To just stand there and wait for me.
Oh, fuck.
Got them right in the barrel.
Get you every time.
Oh my god.
Every time!
It's always a goddamn rat in a barrel.
Oh, there's more.
Oh my god, I didn't mean to burn them.
There's more efficient ways to kill them.
You know what?
Acid!
Easy.
Yeah, they're sleeping in the fish with the fishes tonight.
Okay, nice.
Got their life savings.
They're already dead, so technically it's my life savings
now.
When we find someone, he'll talk.
They always talk.
I've had breakfast that did more damage.
Okay, I gotta save.
Oh, where are they coming from?
Oh.
My little Jazzy.
So I got you now.
Reload.
There you go.
My shotgun's stronger.
Wait, what?
Oh.
My shotgun's stronger.
Oh, that's a lot of...
Oh, it's okay.
They're just guarding.
Oh, no.
I have to be here.
Oh, that's...
Wait, they're cartoonists.
Oh my god, the biggest criminals of all time.
Animators.
Rest in cheese.
That's right.
I knew it.
Yeah.
He just moved.
What the fuck?
What's going on?
How is he dodging all those bullets?
There we go.
His AD was crazy!
I couldn't predict it at all.
Oh, the door is...
Oh, it's from up here.
You're learning the strat.
He's strafing me.
That's illegal!
Okay, you go here.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
There was a...
There was an air duck rat!
Got a vent?
I'm venting?
Oh, it's five?
There you go.
Turning caffeine and panic attacks into someone else's
success.
know they're so easy they haven't unionized yet oh look at
them yes that's right keep animating keep animating where
something's gonna happen I gotta hydrate that's right the
good old days when unions didn't exist And they were paid
one cent per frame.
Actually, no, that's too much.
One cent per hundred frames.
The good old days.
The Disney sweatshops.
Let's go.
Be free, little birds.
This is how they made JJK.
You're free now!
Oh shit, little gas almost got me.
There
you go.
I hear the little rats, though.
I had to heal the little rats first.
Stunlocked!
Oh shit!
He did get stunlocked!
Alright.
Nice.
I think I got everything.
Do I have extra heals anywhere?
No, I drank it all.
Make sure.
Oh, hello.
Oh, the stance, the grit.
You ought to swing by sometime.
Yeah, but she ain't no Victoria.
Oh.
Yeah, you could tell that they are the ones that ain't gonna
make it.
I'm sorry, girl.
Forget about it.
Just do that.
I don't think showbiz is for you, girl.
Oh, damn.
You up for casting, too.
Oh.
Not this door.
Bum!
Oh my god, it's evil.
disney hey you there the name betty lynch ring any bells
yeah of course but uh was that gunfire just now like right
outside gabe clark just shoot the crime picture now about
betty he's still just standing there on the wall he's asking
uh i'm not sure uh after that's just what disney
But, but, um, I know a gal who knew Betty, you know, a
pyrotechnist back from the seekers of the Holy Bree.
She's on set today, so maybe it's worth a shot.
A shot I don't have to dodge for a change.
It's nice.
Alright.
She just mysteriously disappeared like that.
It's so mysterious, like...
The cheesemont mooners.
It was that secret or where I'm supposed secret?
Yeah, I gotta go down into the scary basement.
I bet you there is a rat in one of these barrels.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
What?
They can't do this, I mean.
They can.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
He's right.
Where am I?
All right.
Yes, they can.
Oh, my God.
He was right here.
Where is he?
Oh, my God.
He was right here the entire time.
Oh my god, you teleported.
It's fine.
He hasn't teleported yet.
There we go.
Sneaky rat.
Okay, I'm so paranoid now.
Was that it?
The secret was just rats?
I can't believe it.
The secret was just more rats.
Alright, save.
You call it a trap.
I call it an all-inclusive adventure.
Ah, yes.
A trap where they just gave me a explosive barrel.
The perfect plan!
God damn, I knew it.
Every time.
I'm now so aware.
Wait, there was extra bear.
No, there wasn't.
Bum, bum, bum.
Stratually?
Oh, there was.
And I got health back, too.
Oh, wrong one.
Alright.
Anybody in the bathroom?
Oh, hey, a newspaper.
One of the Mouseburgs Herald's newspaper.
This one holds the release of the Wensley Del Wrath, a
chilling and bestseller penned by one of the Betchaville's
most distinguished novelists.
This narrative weaves through dark alleys, sinister
kidnappings, and anonymously uncovered manholes.
Damn, died doing what he loved.
Reading.
Why were there two rats in here?
Oh, three rats!
Damn!
Alright, I won't judge.
Three rats in the bathroom.
Usni, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Your streams have kept me coming during the last several
months.
So as I grinded the skills to count cards effectively.
Today, I want the most I've ever had on a day.
So I wanted to share some of that for you.
Don't tell the casino.
Oh, yeah, just bros being bros.
You know, just three bros in the bathroom together.
Us just don't get caught, Usni.
on my stream what if they send me a semi those litigation
letters they like show me the super chat record you got the
clowns I'm already yawning never go to the same never go to
the same casino
Twice goes knee.
Sounds like a you problem.
It isn't illegal.
That's true.
Put your photo on there.
There you go.
They got the line up for me.
Oh.
I'll just kick him.
I need my super chats to clean the money.
It's a laundromat now.
Oh, of course it hits me.
Oh my gosh, sometimes like the gun doesn't process.
It's very annoying.
There we go.
Don't you hate it when they just...
When you don't...
When you just grab a pistol instead of your actual gun.
There we go.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Let me see if they said anything.
Oh, alright.
Okay.
Okay, apparently the plushies will not make it.
time for oshi uplink but you're the but the court there will
be coins acrylic blocks and the dog shirts and then my event
manager was like please show the dog so guys this is the
time you can uh you can get the dog shirts at oshi uplink
guys we get them before they sell before they all got the
dog stress will be there in person chat get it before it's
all they're going like crazy guys they're flying off the
shelves get
it before it's too late
again they come with it tired i'm just saying this is a once
a lifetime opportunity those balloons because it's white the
the hangar there i
knew it i fucking knew it i was like that feels way too
parkourable did you say dog shirt and seven thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you speak
with the trap studs man oh where's he at
Oh, freaking topsy-turvy-spinny.
Is that the pyrotechnist?
Oh, that must be him over here.
Oh, my gosh.
Indiana Jones!
It's all that sound.
Oh, it's the crocodile.
Oh, shit!
It was the crocodiles.
Oh, my God.
Did anyone grab the license place off those crocodiles?
They were so fucking fast.
It's not expecting that.
I'll get over there, though.
Come on!
I should have made it.
Are you serious?
That'd be more at the edge.
I don't make those?
Maybe I'll cheese.
Oh, I can't cheese it.
yeah but i want to get i want to go over there thanks man
you're lucky for it where does it must go to another he's
gone real tomb raider chops yourself man yeah he's gone for
a pirate technus do you have uh see um yeah well i can't
think straight right now we've been running forever and i
got he disappeared so i uh i don't know where he moved now
medication a lot of it now I really can't make that next
jump yeah but the biver wait wait wait what kind of
medication does that yeah oh it's just some spike D pills
don't stress it spike D pills all right you gotta do this
scene for me and to pull it off you gotta master an ancient
technique of the tail whip the tail whip basic adventurer
stuff why am I even explaining this so climb up there pull
the lever swing over mid-air grab the last golden idol let's
see it sounds easy boom easy what what okay grab oh i got it
all right take the idol
um put it here turn the lever oh there we go there's my
ability spot grappling hook swing all right nice grab that
you've got the moves kid quite the tomb raider indeed and
then swing back swing back put it down what the what
happened to my hook
oh i forgot i should turn the lever
all right ah crap Oh, shit.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh.
Where do you think it's gonna go?
Alright.
Round one.
Round two.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I'm faster than the rock.
Yeah.
Oh, shit!
Alright, I did not see him there.
scared to grab the money.
Wait, that means I can grapple all the way.
Oh.
Fucking knew it.
Secret.
Am I supposed to be here?
Um, where am I?
Oh, it's a shortcut.
Okay, it was a shortcut.
That's good.
Alright, I was gonna be like, where the fuck did I go?
Oh my god.
I almost sat on my ground.
He got closer?
My god, what is wrong with you?
You're a sniper.
Oh shit, that actually hits me.
Oh.
There we go.
Alright, we did it.
Thank God for these cover boxes.
Okay, never mind.
I take back everything I said about the James gun.
It's pretty OP.
Oh.
I don't trust that.
There's a lot of flaming barrels.
Oh, hey.
Hey, Tammy.
Oh, I guess I don't need that.
I need that for sure you the pyro oh no never mind it's me
all right the best of the best that's not tabby boom you
came to the right I just saw overalls this tabby blast and
no not today I need info on a Betty Lynch Betty yeah I knew
we're all right oh real shame what happened good gal fiery
like a pint-sized Aw, and sweet too.
Always brought me sparkling water.
Aw.
Did you notice anything off about her before she died?
Maybe acting strange, or meeting with the wrong kind of
people.
Man, my man.
This is Dinsal Avenue.
That's like asking if a cheese with holes has holes in it.
Let's just focus on the holes in her story for now, huh?
Well, Betty was a little quirky, but yeah.
Now that I think of it, she met with some guy pretty often.
low profile never left a trailer when he was around real
fancy schmancy suit type you know how they are until Simon
that I hear her trailers gone oh yeah they packed up her
stuff shoved it into one of the generic dressing rooms
standard practice when someone checks out oh oh where is it
just past the medieval set can't miss it I made sure of that
damn I don't even need a Paragate her.
She let it all slip
She revealed it all She's like, oh my gosh, you want me?
You want No more?
I'm here for you
Oh my god, it hurt his His friend's dead body Covered it up
Oh, thank you, Mr. Richad, thank you Thank you
He's a Call of Duty quick scope sniper Run before he 420
knows you across the map.
Thank you.
He's gonna bribe Griffin 360 to jump me.
Let's kick him for the ride.
Yeah, she has very loose lips.
What the fuck?
Where did that guy come from?
He just started to walk.
me oh
my god just drank that too oh it's the medieval set now oh
here's these little guys
now pull this lever oh I can pull the lever cronk might I
pay for this to grade some palm watch the cheese melt and
hear the joyful squeaks of my dinner guests that's
right me and my James gun get out of here but where's the
next next round let me add him
oh fuck not him whoa fuck
there's a lot of them
right here is that sniper oh easy I'm gonna send that over
there while I kick some boxes I gotta start looting Oh,
fuck!
Got that brand in the barrel!
Every time.
Every fucking time.
There's always a god...
I'm shooting from here.
I knew it.
You can't hide from me.
Wasn't all of it for not?
Those grunts worked for a local honor.
An accomplice of my victim.
The guy got suspicious when the stiff started making a move.
Smackeroos then he should have.
And there's a place where he's dead still.
talk.
I could smell him.
Smell that rat in him.
All right, I was gonna say,
well, which way?
Oh, this way.
That means you're slew on this door.
Oh, no, it was just a shortcut.
Oh?
You ever think about a career change?
You wear that piece like it's made for you.
Technus is like, what if we have Tammy at home?
Tammy at home.
But Explosion Junkie in my...
Super.
Thank you for this.
Super Chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
You can make your own Tammy bot at home too.
If you want to.
I know a guy.
Nice.
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
I think I killed them all.
I think I was supposed to like...
Oh, there he is.
Alright, now I've killed them all.
There you go.
Nice.
I'm finally...
Ooh.
Should have used the pistol for this.
works every time oh I'm back here back at the animation
sweatshop
that's right my bullets faster
should be dead from that I don't even cool guys don't look
at acid
I'm trying to quick swap but like I don't know there's like
delay quick swap effect do you see that there's like I don't
know if it's a bug or like or what but it's like so annoying
I could use numbers but I hate using numbers to swap weapons
oh is it intentional okay I was just I don't know if that
was intentional not
it requires a key
Search for clues.
The scroll wheel?
Yeah, but then like, I want to use like, um, specific guns.
Like, I want to go there efficiently, you know?
Huh?
What's this?
Oh, is that the magician?
Oh, no.
Wait, that's Betty?
I don't understand now.
I thought she'd be like You know Like Victoria I don't
understand anymore I don't know But one Sawyer One of the
Merrill candidates Uh Uh Colin Colin Colon note Colin Colon
note is clipped to it Maybe it's like She's not good with
photo you know maybe she looks better in person big mouse
party meeting and standing I mean after you see Victoria I
don't think anybody can compare high-stakes games high-roll
and friends but the higher you yeah I'll just say she ain't
no Jessica Rabbit that's what I'll say she's not someone I
would make three robots for it.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god, a safe within a safe.
Just made it.
Holy shit.
Nice upgrade.
How sad.
Alright, shortcut unlock.
Where am I supposed to go now?
Uh, oh, leave the film studio.
Oh, it's this way.
I'm gonna say, how do I leave?
Where is the exit?
Ha ha!
Uh...
Shroom, it's...
Well, I'm told it goes this way, so I assume the exit is
somewhere here, right?
Where is the exit?
Ah!
Ha ha ha ha!
Why did it tell me to go there?
I would assume the exit was like this way.
But it took me to go up the ladder.
Wouldn't the exit be back here?
Oh my god.
Yeah, like back here?
Oh, now where I put...
Oh, the phone is where I picked up.
the fuck god damn it oh now i don't even i need to fucking
figure out how to get back
okay try to remember where i picked up their photo it's all
blurring together who was her dressing room here no that's
not it where was her dressing room
guys it's been a while oh it's up here
I do.
Yeah, this is our dressing room.
Where's the phone?
I was told there was a phone here.
Oh, there's the phone.
I did it.
I found the phone.
Wee.
Alright, one martini on the road.
Surprisingly, not a lot of boss fights.
I really like the boss fights.
Ditch that tensile stench.
Now it's time for a quick word with Vivian.
Oh sorry, Vivian.
Not Victoria.
Alright, let's upgrade the James gun.
Yeah, I like the boss fights.
I wish there were more of it.
Because I actually enjoy the boss fights a lot.
I don't know if I should keep buying the newspapers.
No, I'll buy one per level.
One of the master, it recounts the infamous puddle scandal
where the mayor promised to fix leaky sewers in the master
turned out to be a plan and simply covered them with rugs.
Is there a boss fight in my next level chat?
Does anyone know?
Well, you were right, Wanda.
I found something at the studio after all.
That is very interesting, Jack.
More interesting than a truck full of spiked e-fondoo Or a
truckload of bug-ridden cheese Feels like we're just
scratching the surface Mixing show business with politics
Hardly a recipe for a long life Alright Save our game Oh,
hey there, Vivian Wait, let me put my clues down
Alright, it's quick to clean up Betty Lynch's belongings
coincidence i think not all right now we can talk so
monsieur pepe have you found out anything about my poor late
friend you already got plenty of charm why bury it under
that uh accent it's called movie business all right mr pepe
wait you're not even french did you find anything i trust
nobody in show business you know who killed betty not yet
but it seems she was quite the socialite she was getting
rather close with that uh what's he knew it i knew it oh
soyer milford you're so luckable she most likely got the
soyer through that dandy spokesman for their party names the
gas oh miles curd yes of course oh the parties we threw Oh,
such lavish affairs.
So, Mr. Pepper, how do you plan to get close to Sawyer?
He's probably less approachable by men, shall we say,
particularly men in trench coats who ask a lot of questions.
We're going to honeypot him.
That may be.
I've seen my loony tunes.
If Bug's buddy can do it, so can I.
If Sawyer's unreachable, why not miles curd he's a beast of
a different sort altogether not really he's a mouse too but
i get your point good mr pepper i believe your best bet is
to go and catch miles from what i gather he's either
throwing another party or cleaning up the mess at the opera
house what's left of it anyway oh someone made a mess at the
opera what could do that truly barbara historical venue too.
I feel like Bugs Bunny is like the cross-dresser.
Time to run out of the flagpole and see who salutes.
Like the people's cross-dresser.
Movement.
Nobody can do it like bugs.
Oh yeah, I see the new kite.
Oh, not new but you remember that coyote film coyote versus
wally coyote versus acne and a trailer came out and it
looked like bug's bunny is gonna be like a villain in the
trailer like he looks like he's gonna be like acne is one of
acne's henchmen i was like oh my god evil bug's bunny the
place was cleaning up nice clear as day curd hadn't lifted a
finger and clear eyes should keep my mouth shut
Oh.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
Joink.
Hmm.
I don't know how I feel about...
I don't know.
I saw the trailer.
But it feels like...
Not as...
You know how they're like...
The actors were like, it's such a good movie i don't maybe
it will be a really good movie but the trailer was not that
impressive for me i guess it was weird the animation style
was so weird it's like 3d slash 2d at the same time i was
not expecting the animation style oh you know what movie i'm
like super excited about the sheep one the sheep one looks
so good i've actually been i remember seeing a trailer of it
and was like really wanting to watch it I see a what a weird
staircase right there John told me the guy had an ex and a
kid apparently has a 97% approval rating
it's like basically it's like the sheep the shepherd it's
like a bunch of sheep trying to solve the murder of the
shepherd and their shepherd Redford is Hugh Jackman.
I thought I was going to stop.
I was supposed to shoot that.
It looked really good, though.
Oh, hey, guys.
Yeah, it's a murder mystery.
Where a bunch of sheep is trying to solve the murder.
Apparently, it's, like, really funny.
Now, if you'll excuse me, I'm in the middle of...
Oh, watching other people do the actual work.
Um, it's called being a supervisor.
Mr. Kurt, I'm investigating the unfortunate demise of one
Betty Lynch.
It's a very hard job.
My oral candidate, Milford Sawyer, knew her.
Might even be useful in figuring out how she ended up dead.
And who the hell are you?
I don't remember seeing you around the MPD headquarters.
And I know all our good investigators.
investigators.
Maha.
How were?
What was that?
Man, just a cough.
Names.
Jack Pepper.
P .I.
for hire.
Not here on official business.
Yeah, it's the sheep detective.
Everyone watch that one.
The thing is, this whole case has a, uh, how do I put it?
A spoiled way kind of stink.
You might want to help me out before that smell starts
sticking to you too.
Pepper.
All right, fine.
We're two of you.
close to the election for some half-baked accusations to
start fouling up the campaign, shoot your shot.
Already did.
So was Sawyer close to Betty in any way?
No chance.
Maybe they clinked glasses at some movie fundraisers, but
that's it.
I'm the one riding shotgun in Sawyer's inner circle.
If there was more, I'd know.
Could he have kept it quiet?
You know, to avoid the kind of scandal that might make a
Watch your tongue, Peppa.
When you're a public figure like Milford, small-time celebs
show up whether you want them or not.
Hoping to ride your coattails.
Doesn't mean there's more to it than that.
Oh, see, that's funny because I got pictures.
Betty rubbing elbows with BMP officials.
We have proof.
So why are you lying?
Yeah, because she was always circling our parties like some
famous hungry woman.
every starlet and wannabe socialite looking for a headline
but trust me there's some accusations you got there miles
mixed business with that oh had a personal gripe with by did
she reject him is there something i should listen pepper
shaker i don't like where this is going so i'm giving you
one last polite i bet he was jealous yeah damn betty
catching some straight she's already Get the hell out of my
yard.
I'm sure slammed it against the wall in my for my
interrogation.
Lucky I still had my teeth and plenty left to chew on.
Nice, I didn't have to fight for it.
Fight for the information.
Back to my PI office.
Feels like a dead end leading to a burning dumpster.
Maybe Vivian can make sense of the mess.
All right, does anyone want to talk to me?
Oh, he wants to talk.
Hello, Cornelius.
Tell me, Cornie, why do we always meet in these seedy
places?
Hey, doesn't he have to, like...
Screw you, Peppa.
This is a well-respected establishment.
Who's talking to me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Real high class.
So...
Oh, okay.
It was John, the shrew.
You've got to understand.
Yeah, I was going to say, why is he still here?
Doesn't he have a campaign to run?
That you are.
friends are friends but business is business so what you're
really saying is you're ashamed of being friends
bottom-shelf private dick after the war we've been through
so much oh come on you know how these things work what keeps
the wheels turning sure money but it should be backbone
Damn.
I can't believe it.
After all I did for him.
God, he's changed.
Oh, I should have left him.
Alright.
Let's put up all our clues up.
Oh, resolved lead.
Now just need a mooring point.
I hate to ask, but Tam knows these waters better than I do.
Okay, it's this Betty and we're nothing just casual, just a
friendship, just an evening.
That's what they all say.
That's right.
I saw where's that hat?
Oh, wait, right here.
Okay, I was gonna say I saw where that hat was right here
next to him.
Asmiles, create above Betty Lynch, and he's ironed.
Tight-lipped revolver.
There's much more under the rind here.
Something he doesn't want in surface.
oh he was jealous oh maybe betty chose soyer over miles wait
they both look the same are they twins
are these two twins wait a minute wait they're twins it's
like they do the same math he chose this this is this in
this Milford, Milford Sawyer, and then this is Miles Curd.
Why are they not the same last name?
Yeah, but why do they look the same?
Maybe they're just best friends.
Same butting everything.
Oh my god, Betty chose Sawyer and Curd got mad.
Half brothers, cousins?
Like even i guess one's older one is more wrinkled they have
different hair maybe a wig seems sus she just is the proud
of black and white films any progress on the case separated
at birth yeah and it reeks worse than the brie i left
sitting in the fridge i don't see a fridge exactly but i did
cross paths with Mr. Curd.
And?
And he clammed up quicker than a marina shellfish in a
cheese storm.
Still, I found out that while Betty got close to Sawyer,
she, uh, well, how do I put it?
She befriended Curd as well, but... Yes.
Quick, out with it.
See, here's where it gets kooky, like real kooky.
Curd spoke of her like she was nothing more than a bottom of
the barrel winch, and then threatens to slap me with a
lawsuit like I'm some snooty millionaire.
I was like, where are you going to get from me?
I'm a detective.
Look where I live.
Could be.
At least I know what to go to next.
You see, Kurds got dirt close to home.
Literally.
So that's where I'm heading.
So you're leaving town, Mr. Pepper.
Just for a little while.
Good.
Go do your thing.
I'll poke around here and there.
I have a few friends in, let's say, mid to high places.
You take care, Mr. Pepper.
Oh, I will.
All right, we're ahead to...
Oh, ask Tammy about the liaisons.
Or the liaisons.
All right.
Hello, Tammy.
Can you tell me more?
Hey, Jack.
How's the case shaping up?
You know, the shrews and all that.
Hey, kiddo.
I'm heading down...
the wall of bay to find out the bay huh what's dragging you
down this salty armpit now well i just follow the crumbs you
know they're pointing me straight to the water supposedly
that's where the shrews are being moved i just have to pin
down the exact spot well hey i might be able to help you out
with that oh figured you might who's my guy yeah so who's my
guy names Cameron Cameron rakes like a jug away yes but you
might have heard something useful you'll find him skulking
around the pub likely cam bozo classy oh and be sure to have
a bunch of cheddar handy cheddar what's wrong with guta no
guta if you broke jack oh now it teaches me about the ultra
defy all right head to wallabay and curdsville all right we
have two areas we gotta go to solve the mystery so i can
finally get paid but we'll have that next stream because i'm
ep now did i save yeah i did all right guys we'll figure out
we'll solve the mystery next stream am i even 50 done chat i
just want to know because if i might do a long part three
next stream no yeah
I'm gonna go out of here I need to make my schedule uh I
think if I don't have anything if it's not confirmed by
today by end of today I'm just gonna put like free space on
that on Friday because I don't know it's just gonna be a
free space because I don't know if if like I I'm I'm in the
thing or not.
The EP comes for us all.
It always comes for us.
Quill, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How filled out the board is the indicator?
How filled out is it?
Oh, we're missing the middle portion here.
It's just...
I guess we're 50% done.
I'm pretty sure.
I didn't even do a long stream for part 3 and then finish
the game because I do enjoy it.
I like...
I think when I figure out the movement, like part 1 was when
I was like trying to figure out the movement tech and the
how to play and then now i'm like more used to now i'm more
used to it i think like part three i can breeze through it
now i am making really good progress hey guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye